One. Huh, Huh. Huh?
Oh boy. Hey everybody. What
the fuck's going on? Hey,
I've been away a while, but I missed you
guys. How long have you been away for?
Four days or something. They
took a week off. I was, uh,
I was out of town.
Um,
this episode of the podcast is
brought to you by Squarespace. Uh,
there's probably about five
or six websites out there
dedicated to various parts
of our body that have been made during
the construction of this very podcast.
It's that easy to make websites.
Squarespace a allows you to
make your own website, um,
with just simple web tools, drag
and drop interface. Very easy to do.
It's nothing complex. It's
nothing that, uh, the average, uh,
dim wit that knows a little bit
about computers like myself can do.
It's just they've figured it out.
They figured out how to streamline it.
Now with Dan, just drag and drop.
Everything's drag and drop. It says what?
It puts stuff. Yeah. And you can
make websites that look really good.
It used to be fully, yeah, I like
a different looking portfolio.
How about this online store set
up an online store, super easy,
beautiful design for you to start with.
Use Your own images or handbags or
she could still pictures of your Dick
mentioned that you guys made a
living selling pictures. You Dick,
your wife just takes pictures of his
Dick and sells him a little bit of mouth.
Not Bad,
but I'm an excellent photographer.
If it was real easy to buy shit online,
if everything was like Amazon one click,
you know, and I landed on the pay
like 5 cents to see your Dick. I know,
you know for people. Yeah.
People would. People would say,
I want to see Ariz tick this. A
few people that would, right? Yeah.
Like saying about how much like
let's get weird. Ellen degenerates.
If Ellen degenerate took pictures
of her butthole and he needed,
it costs you 5 cents to see it.
How many fucking people would pay if
it was really easy to pay that for?
For her vagina.
I think it's going to come to that.
If I didn't have to open
my wallet. Yeah. If you,
if it was super easy to do her like
it was just the back from a dollar,
it was just a word interface. Like do
you want to pay 5 cents to see Ellen's?
Yeah,
I'll see.
I'll do it and the computer knows and I'll
have it back to pretend. Yeah, and you,
you're allowed to not even take like a
breathalyzer test for anything under a
certain amount of money after
a certain amount of money.
It should be like the responsibility of
the manufacturer of the cell phone to
make some sort of a breathalyzer thing
because otherwise it's too fucking easy
to just buy shit. If you're
really hammered and you buy
something, buy everything.
Yeah, it's rude. You can't have that
pill and call him that for a long time.
Breathalyzer for your,
for your phone or your computer.
It's a good move for text messages and
the thing that you sent after two o'clock
in the morning.
It's most likely a mistake.
Most likely when I get to high late at
night, I buy so much things. Of course.
Beautiful, beautiful,
beautiful and awesome,
and you can make a website about
those things. Start Your own business.
You fuck resell your shitty purchases.
Go to squarespace.com you
can make your logo creator.
You can create a sleek and simple logo
for Ari and I doing that big juicy hog
Ari Shaffir, a big juicy hog
and it's a picture of a chicken.
It makes zero sense and it's perfect.
And for a free trial and
10% off your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and enter
in the code word Joe. Yeah,
they're all different. Oh, that just
a minute. Are you sure? What is it?
The tee shirts and big juicy, juicy
y'all. It's an h AWG core science.
That's the way to say it.
Sounds more delicious that we start
with how it sounds or slurpee.
It's online.
Then it be getting mad at all of
these gay and you windows and jokes.
You rule this spool and homophobic
shit and all this folk and listen.
I like Dick Jokes. I think they're
funny. If you get, you get weirded out,
that's your own shit, son. All right,
don't panic. Dick. Jokes are funny.
Go to squarespace.com make
your room Dick joke website.
One cool thing about it though, one cool
thing about it covert Joe is that, um,
you could actually build the site and
then not pay for it yet and then decide
like, all right, I'm going to go
like, yeah, that is a good word.
That is a good a idea.
Rather they,
they're so confident in their ability to
make a website so easily that they let
you try it out,
register and try it out without
entering your credit card information.
So at the end of that,
if you'd like you websites wax on
whale and you can just bail and uh,
you'll have learned about
that surface anyway,
go to squarespace.com use the
code word Joe and save 10% off.
And more importantly to me, I meant the
Squarespace people. They're very nice.
They're cool. Where'd you meet him in
New York? I'm in New York or whatever.
The officer's super friendly.
Everybody that they came to the show,
they're really friendly and nice and fun
though. Okay. Internet company, man. Yeah,
it's cool people.
Those are the cool people.
That's why I have faith in the
future. People are always like, well,
here's uhthe you fucking yours.
Looking at the word toad things, man,
we're going down the toilet.
I have faith in the future because I
think that technology and the technology
creators are the ones that are
dictating what's taking place.
Everyone is scrambling to deal with the
technology owners. Innovators, yeah.
Before,
well instead of actual products,
solid items instead of solid items and
things that you weigh and put it on a
scale and said you're dealing with
things like a Google. I mean it's,
there's a solid item somewhere.
You know,
there's hard drives that keep all the
information on and obviously there's
offices,
but the reality is that Google is not
a real product that you can pick up and
having your hand. You can have a Google
phone, but what the fuck is Google? Well,
the number one thing in that company is
that nothing. It's an air. It's an idea.
So this idea has picked up all these
hard drives and set up all these web
browsers and set up all these different
Google chrome and Google operating
system based on nothing. But what
is it really? It's just ideas.
It's an idea is what Google is and
there are really ethical and responsible
company, which is fascinating
because one of the most powerful,
one of the Mo is also very progressive.
There's super progressive,
I have a friend who works at Google.
There's a guy who works in the office
who's a guy outside the office,
but in the office he likes to be referred
to as a woman and he dresses up as a
woman. So he goes to the office,
he dresses up as like, like a man,
just like a woman.
He's a man until he gets to the office.
Then he goes to the office at
work. Yup. Yup. Like Klinger.
He just knows he's not trying to
get a thing from the government.
It's just what he does. And Google's
like, okay, as long as you're nice,
like long as you did your work and
what do we care? What do we care?
That's perfect. This easy that
didn't exist in older, older.
Why does he wear a regular boy suit
to work? That's a very good question.
But a better question is why does anybody,
why can you identify someone
sex by the clothing they wear?
That seems like the most ridiculous thing.
Which people in a certain ways a bank.
Yeah.
I used to when I was religious and worked
at some law firm for the summer and
then the next year I
like lost my religion.
Then that summer and then I worked there
again like a goddamn rem song and I
didn't want to explain to them.
So I would just take my Yamaha off.
As soon as I left work I would
put it on to work and take it off.
So yeah, man, um, I,
I have faith because of that,
because he's smart.
Mother fuckers are the ones that are
the ones that are the most innovative,
the ones that are the most on the
cutting edge of about what's changing the
world. Like Google searches or changing
the goddamn world. Right. And then China,
you can't get on Google. It's
Google is a crazy thing. Yeah.
The ability to just get all the
questions. I mean, not always, right.
A lot of contrary information,
but just the sheer bulk of the
information and then sources, oh,
this is a Stanford University study,
and he'd go, okay. You know? Right.
You know what I mean? You just start
reading things like, oh, this, uh,
this guy's a professor of astronomy from
Cambridge, and he says this knowledge.
Yeah. You Go, okay, well,
this guy's super legit.
He's a professor of astronomy
at Cambridge. You know?
It's like that didn't,
we didn't have,
all you have is a microfiche for
newspapers and all these dudes that are in
involved in these companies.
In my opinion, it seems to
be they're moving. I mean,
it's, there's still, corporations
are still going to be,
there's always going to be
weirdness when money's involved,
but it seems like the
ethic of the Internet,
the ethic of these electronic corporations
is one of social responsibility.
One that didn't really exist before.
I'm trying to think of as any bad,
bad of those companies.
Not that I can think of like Tesla.
They're supposed to be really cool.
Elon Musk has got a reputation of being
is really fascinating. Innovative guys.
Starbucks is cool.
Starbucks is cool as fuck.
I love having good coffee on the
corner for people's health insurance.
They offered to put your through Phoenix
online college. Daily checkup. Yeah.
24 25 like we'll pay for it to full.
That's beautiful.
I think that shit is possible,
man.
I think people can build it and
the ethical competent, you know,
I can't really do, I just think that for
so long people are so God damn ruthless.
So people say, Ooh, you know, you
was fucking sue up and history.
They've been doing it for years.
Yeah.
Ben and Jerry had been doing it like I
Richard back before. It was interesting.
Like we're just going to do
it cause it's the right thing.
Well they're from Vermont. Vermont is,
if you ever been up there at Burlington,
Vermont. Oh yeah. Once my parents
tried to send me to a special camp.
They're so beautiful. Beautiful
Town. God, Vermont is awesome.
This is higher ground.
Ready to go to that higher ground place.
What's higher ground? Some like small
like rock theater. Ooh, like hers. Cool.
Maybe I worked at,
cause I definitely work something
in Burlington a long time ago. Yeah,
I guess we're doing a podcast. Let's
just fucking go with it. Um, uh,
I did something in Burlington. We, I mean
clearly we were done with commercials.
Nature's box yet. Yeah. Naturebox go
fuck yourself. Give me some yummy treats.
Do you have,
where are they going to stop?
Because I was going to say I
actually made a Squarespace a store.
I'm working on one right now and it
was so fucking easy how you just put a
picture in of what you want to sell.
You put how many either is that quantity.
There is a,
you sign up for this thing that's like
paypal and then if somebody buys it from
you, it uh, autumn in two days it
automatically goes to your bank account,
the money and it sends you like a little
shipping thing where to ship it to you.
I mean it is incredible.
I was so blown away how easy a store
was because I knew blog kind of thing,
websites and stuff. I knew it couldn't
be that hard because I used wordpress,
this store thing. I was so amazed at how
easy it was, how much control you had.
And Squarespace I'm you can make a store
in less than five minutes is really
that crazy. Just like paypal
store. Did you use paper?
It uses a,
a another company that's just like how
I could just use a credit card so you
don't have to have a pig. Right, right.
So if someone has a paper
on the ones that's crazy.
It's just pretty much a credit card
processor that charges I think, uh,
like three, 5 cents per transaction. So,
and that's actually cheaper
than what paypal does.
Cause I believe paypal actually
uses a percent of how much money.
So if you have $100, paypal
takes like $11, you know,
it's like 11% where this actual
company, whatever, I forget,
it's like spark or something.
Uh,
actually only just charges you 35
cents cause all it is is a credit card
transaction fee. Right, right.
So we're just moving numbers around in
the ether so we don't care how big your
transaction is. The same process
for them, right? A scam. Yeah.
Make money by moving numbers on computers.
Fucking ticket master always does that.
Garbage to Ticketmaster. Why is it on?
We bought four tickets all at once.
Why the four processing fee?
What's a processing fee? The computer's
doing it. He talking about it.
I didn't call the hotline.
Well that's what the big argument
with that band in Seattle was about.
Pearl Jam.
Remember Pearl jam like they rallied
against ticket master and I talked to
someone over there and they were like,
no,
it's the venues that they
want their percentage that
they take it too. It's like,
well then why don't you put it as a
venue costs. We know who to blame.
Look at that face you're making.
Let's see your shows that people like
your tickets with $35 I paid 66 and you're
like, what? Yeah. Yeah. It's weird.
But that's how it is, you know,
I would love to rally
against shit like that,
but I don't have that kind of time so
I just got to keep pressing forward.
You know,
I think Louis for awhile I was doing some
weird shit where he's making people in
cash and they had,
yeah,
they had to buy it like the day of the
show and then a paint [inaudible] sir,
he did that at the comedy
store. I know that, you know,
the idea was to stop scalper suit because
there's always a scalping problem.
That's, that always happens if you're
going to sell out of place like uh,
like a ticket master. Um, like someone
who buys it from ticket master some,
you know, some company pops, whatever.
Long time ago Robin Williams played and
it was like sold out and I was like,
why didn't we get, people are offering
to pay like $150, $200 for tickets.
I'm like, what? We had access to
them. We never scalped at the store.
Somebody must've,
right.
Somebody must've gotten people like
chewy had to scalp a little bit.
I did it this year.
They just get some scalp and then
Louie tickets for for a few for you,
for someone else,
and then you couldn't go.
The other person couldn't get scalped
him. I told the doorman, I was like, Hey,
you can sell them, get whatever you want
over the 40 buck and then take the rest.
Ooh, he doubled it. Ooh. Yeah.
People can't get into like,
well, what do you want? What do you
want? Let's do this. Especially in La,
right in La.
People that come on,
this restaurant's got to have two seats
somewhere. I'm in fortunate paper,
Sean Paul on nine Dash Week.
Alright,
keep going with a commercial naturebox.
Naturebox.
Don't fuck.
Go Fuck Yourself.
When I said that before I was
treating you like a buddy,
I just got my first nature bucks
today. Man. I was really, really happy.
He just sent me two packages of
Serratia Kashi, so Roger Catches,
oh my goodness. I forgot
to bring them in, man.
I went home and I forgot to bring them
in. They're so good. You would die.
You would want them delivered
to your house every day.
Do the best snack I've
ever had. These Sharat your
cashews? Nope, that's not true.
I got some elk jerky from amazon.com
I know you can buy some elk Jerky,
so that's pretty God damn good too.
But a Sriracha cashews.
As far as like being a of an option where
nothing had to die. That's an animal.
A better for you than chips. Elk.
No, the chips. Oh yeah. Nuts.
You're way better than theirs either.
The salted and roasted and stuff.
It's still like these are,
that's what Scott would be
more easy to process, right?
It's definitely,
well,
what's more easy to process about
everything that naturebox has is that they
have no trans fats. Trans fats, your
body has a process issue with those. Uh,
high fructose corn syrup.
Nazi Holocaust survivors are living such
a long life because no high fructose
corn syrup, no trans fats for
awhile. That's what it is.
Yet another living at 100 and something
that's amazing. Imagine if that's true.
I can't pay that.
No imaginable.
Really blessed those foods. I the
GF food kosher, it's called kosher.
Don't take Jew food.
They look over and make sure you,
people like you aren't doing anything to
it. Of course, according to a license,
you're not supposed to say [inaudible]
you supposed to say Jewish.
And if you could say someone's a Jew
that it's like an insult. Really. No, no,
I've heard that before.
It's the first time I've actually
heard the girls say that according to a
license slash ginger, no, people would
get upset if you call someone a Jew.
Yeah. I, uh, zero,
zero high fructose corn syrup to a nothing
artificial free shipping anywhere in
the u s uh, if you, if you have a,
an office vending machine and they're
like the best thing that you can eat in
there as peanuts, you know those fucking
machines. What's this? Candy bar chips.
Peanuts,
I guess put some naturebox and your desk.
So Dropbox or Jews
always allowed to say that,
you know,
why do privilege privilege the animals?
And I was like,
that's kind of cool if just like this
old Jewish guy that came over there and
just like,
all right guys,
I look over the killing and they make
sure it's all killed, right? In theory,
I think that kosher was
a great idea at first.
They just set some ground rules like
don't eat pigs. They're dirty fuckers.
People were probably getting sick like
crazy if they didn't know how to cook
animals. If you cook a pig
the same way you kick a deer,
you're going to have real problems.
Uh, pigs are they, they're omnivores.
They eat a lot of animals and so they
get tricked Canosa so you have to get a
cook the shit out of it.
You gotta you're going to eat that
parasite to when you eat a pig that
they did not really know where to get
fucking try mushrooms and get sat from a
tree,
but they didn't know why do we keep
getting sick every time we get this pig?
Well, they just thought the pig was
disgusting. They thought if you eat pig,
you're going to get sick and you're
going to die. It makes sense cause back.
That is true. Yeah. I mean, back then
you had a real issue and most pigs,
whether they were wild or domestic,
apparently the exact same thing,
the same animal, just they
just look different, you know?
But they could fuck with each other.
They can interbreed you know,
it was a really weren't allowed
to accept when they said,
why is it tough not kosher?
Because you know, it's, it's
the tapeworm stuff. Mm. Uh,
the answer was always, cause God
said, that's a good mo. Good answer.
You're not supposed to know why. Yeah,
you don't need to know bitch. God said,
God said, stay away from the
fucking pigs. But, uh, you know,
now that we know it's silly because bacon
is awesome and nobody dies from Bacon,
Bacon today. I mean, you could buy
from, you could die from [inaudible].
How about some bacon flavor and stuff?
Do that beef Jerky in here?
They don't have beef jerky. No, but
I'll tell you what they do have.
They have those south Pacific plantations.
God Damn, those are good. Woo.
And that big island pineapple. Oh
Yum. Yum. Yum. Yum. But I keep going.
Those Sriracha cashews, everything.
I didn't have any big unrelated,
now that I think about it,
they need
to ward off the juice.
Pickles,
pickles, a tricky man. You know
Grillo's pickles, by the way.
How's greatest pickles in the
history of the free world?
They don't need to make pickles.
When Grillo's pickles show up at,
they were just giving them out. What was
that was our show in Boston and Boston.
Yeah. The dude from Grillo's pickles,
cools, cools. Fucking Grillo's pickles.
I am not bullshitting you.
The best pickles I've ever had in my life.
People were like, what's the
big deal with pickles? Bitch,
listen to me just by yourself and
the one container of those hot,
spicy. Spicy. Yeah. Oh my
God, they're so fucking good.
Big Island pineapple is all so delicious
that love that snack and nothing
simple, dried. So
good. And what's cool about
nature of boxes that you know you,
you get this once a month and you could
add any other snack for only $3 extra so
you can just load up your box.
Like I love it.
No problem. Don't go to nature's
box, naturebox, naturebox nature.
It's a chick named nature and uh,
it's, it's all boxes. Disgusting.
It's all about her. Her Butt
problem. Got One of those.
If you're doing ads on each of these
people ever save him for like [inaudible]
not really an ad. I mean there's
sort of a podcast ad. Yeah. Anyway,
naturebox.com/rogan socket, that's
enough. We don't need to do on it today.
We'll do it later on.com. Use
the code word Rogan Sam. Boom.
I move like a ghost
experience.
We said a lot of cool shit
before this podcast ever started.
We have a Nick Diaz calling through our
punchdrunk sports podcast. Oh really?
He's going to call in? Uh, well
we have allegedly, allegedly,
he calls it all the time. How did you do
punch drunk when you were on the road?
China. I love doing it from other
places. I did it from the slopes in Vail.
Was Holy Shit, I should have a guest or
did you do it by yourself? Punch drunk?
No, no, no. Like you called in
Skype. Okay, so you did it from,
from remote locations? Yeah,
from the slopes and veil.
Like I pulled over into the woods and I
was until my phone went off because it
was too cold. It's always
been like, where are you?
I did it from the shower once we came
back from break and I was just like and
see if I was like,
are you fucking showering?
What is the audio like when you're
skyping like into a podcast?
Pretty good as long as I have Wifi so
you could but you're trying to do it on
four g LTE and it works. Yeah,
but sometimes it goes like, especially
in New York, it's like comes in and out.
It seems like there would be a really
cool way to do a podcast walking around
AAA.
It's very like room echo,
Edo, that good part.
What you could do though is you could
record it separately like on an MP three
player and then send them the audio
later and they could cut it in.
So it sounds fun.
Have two recordings going simultaneously
and they would have to sync them up.
Right.
The live one would be the only one there
that seems like a project that we would
give to you and it would take at least a
year
or two reasons why.
I know that that's not going to happen.
But I'm so happy.
Your video editing again,
that video of us shooting hard drives,
we just had to shoot hard drives.
Hard drives. Yeah. So we uh, you know,
that's funny.
No for fun than anything,
but I always wanted to know what
happens when a bullet hits a hard drive.
So all drives and load up my
hunting rifle. Really? Yeah.
It's a serious rifle. It's a seven
millimeter Remington ultra mag.
They just let go through it. Oh yeah,
yeah. It went through. It's sideways too.
Like it's, it's so accurate.
You could hit it with wise.
So you're at something that's
a hundred yards away and
you have about an inch,
maybe a little more inch and a half or
some points that you can see. This is a,
this is us shooting that the heart
drive,
as long as you stay put,
it's all just about staying put and
not freaking out. Freaking out. Yeah.
When you pull the trigger,
don't flinch.
It's really hard not to flinch
because you got a rifle man
gun rifle breathe out. Yeah. I mean that
thing that has a muzzle break on it,
which is this thing around the
tip of the uh, the rifle bolt,
the a rifle barrel rather that
it distributes the energy better.
Makes a louder noise though.
So it doesn't,
it's a hundred yards and it does so
it doesn't, um, it doesn't, um, uh,
kick as much,
which is really important because of the
kick is what scares the shit out of Uli.
Yeah. Clinch up before it
happens. Yeah. Tense up.
How do we get to talking
about this hard drive?
Destruction were we were on a
Securitas route. Oh, your video.
I'm glad you're doing video.
Yeah, man, it's so cool to
see you doing videos again.
Somebody put up a thread of
some of your old videos. Dude,
you're so talented at that. It's like
you have such a gift for video editing.
I quickly learned know how to,
how using like editing HD nowadays,
how much fucking computer you need
though to make it even worth not killing
yourself.
Trying to do as far as,
well I don't just edit videos like that.
The videos I do,
there's like at least that had like at
least 12 layers of audio going on at the
same time.
Is there some sort of super dope set up
that we can get that would convince you
to start making money?
Well, I mean this, I mean this one was fun
to do but it, you know, I don't know. I
dude, you could make the, you make,
you were making amazing videos,
submission video for some, some strong
comments. That should never happen. Yeah,
it has like a million views are, I'm
rolling. It has a lot and I was like, wow,
I got that man know you've
got some real talent,
real talent as far as like how you choose
scenes and edit things and music and
effects into them.
You're really good.
It's like you don't just take a video
and cut it together and edit it.
You add something to it. You
add a lot to it. You know,
you made some awesome videos when we
were working together. Doing those.
Taylor always looked good.
David Taylor says that he was like,
you're the first guy to figure out length
on the Internet without Mitzia clip.
It'll like, how do you make a 10 minute
long clip? But people will actually watch.
There's no way. It hasn't been naked
like a show. Make it look a little show.
You have a timeline going on. I mean it
goes back in time and forward in time.
Nowadays it is getting easier.
The actual programs like the new final
cut pro is cool cause it could sync up
automatically where it used to have to
just try to line up to yeah, yeah it
was. And stuff like that. Go go to
saint. Wow. That should be a thing. Yeah.
Jama computers into this man.
I mean it would be fun to see how,
how much unstressful some Adderall.
We'll get you whatever you allegedly
allegedly, this is a comedy show.
We're not being do. Take us to a cage
out of all that motherfucker up. Yeah.
That was talking, working, talking. Dude,
dude today, recently quit Adderall. Right.
Really? Yeah. We're having a conversation
while, you know, he was cool. He ran out.
Very cool guy. No, I
think he felt like that.
I think a lot of people that do the
Adderall feel like there's a crash at the
end of the day.
Oh you got to have the inside of the fast
acting ones or the time release ones.
Yeah. So there was no crash that way.
Is it like they slowly lead you off,
boom and drop off a cliff. But he was
loving the Adderall. I got to get us on.
He was telling me how productive and
really cause he self medicating that one.
I do not believe so,
but I didn't ask.
I believe he was talking about a doctor.
It works so much differently when you're
like can need it or when you don't.
It feels like the opposite thing to
you if you need it. Allegedly. Uh,
I don't understand add, but if
you, cause I have it hardcore,
I don't understand it, but I think if
you, um, if you have it and then you take,
it calms you. It centers you. Is that
true though? I Dunno. That's what I heard.
I don't know. I have no, it's so hard
to tell what the fuck is going on.
It's like you ever, uh, see someone
drink and then they just lose their moms.
They just, for whatever reason,
they just lose their marbles.
The brain just shuts off.
They're not there anymore.
They make terrible decisions.
You're like,
how many fucking drinks have you had?
He's only had like three drinks and
they just go away. They just go away.
I can't get that. You don't get that? I
don't know. Just barf. Right. Pass out.
But I mean, do you get that guy? Oh,
understand it. Yeah. You tried to get,
do you try to get it, cause obviously
something's happening to him.
I think he's a very direct,
there's a distinctly different
physiological effect of
alcohol on his body as
opposed to your body. You and I have
gotten drunk a bunch of times together.
You just argue she feared drunk. Yeah.
You know, there's nothing crazy at all.
You're, you, you're exactly the same
guy, but you'll laugh a little bit more.
You sit,
you'll be a little bit more ridiculous.
Like all of us were drunk at looser,
but there are certain folks that they
go away and then this other guys there,
this is a love.
That's my favorite thing is to say like
they're not making memories right now.
Nope, this is all just unrecorded.
What's really fucked up?
It's like they're in a dream that's that's
there's people that have a real issue
like that. The sign of alcoholism, you
black out, that means you're an alcoholic,
but be like, what do you mean? I blacked
out like a hundred times. Like, yeah,
but there is something to say like I've
been freaking myself out because I mean
I like to drink,
but it seems like every night I come home,
like I don't remember the last hour like
at all, but then I'm thinking, wait,
I only had three drinks.
That's like,
I think there's also a lot to do with how
much you smoke weed, alcohol together.
Both jump off. Yeah, because
I know that's in both.
Like jumpstart it.
Like right now today I've only smoked
weed and I really don't remember what I
did last like two hours ago.
I,
I'm just trying to remember that you
didn't get much sleep last night either,
right? Yeah. Yeah. It happens a lot though
where like I come home and I'm like,
well I don't remember much last
night but I smoked like 14 joints.
Smoking
14 joints is probably a bad idea,
but what's a good idea for
you is definitely to take
a break off the booze and
that's this week cause you're,
you're healthy.
I mean look what you did with your life
as far as like have fun over the last
few years. Go Party, you know, just
be at the comedy clubs all the time.
It's a great fun thing that's
so few people get to do.
There's nothing wrong with doing it.
It's like do you do it and manage how
much damage you do to yourself in the
process and a certain point in time.
I just feel that most
folks can't keep drinking.
Most folks to get to a
certain point in time.
There's always stories about
some guy was a hundred years old,
smoked cigarettes and, but that guy,
the reason why you hear those stories,
that's unusual as fuck. Most people
when they get to be, you know,
50, 60, when they're smokers,
they start having real problems,
like extreme problems.
She throws, her grandfather drank
every day until he died. I'm like,
how often does your hanging
out with her grandfather,
he's over there and check it off
and eat and tobacco. Yeah, there's,
I don't know how much of it is true.
You know,
I know there's always a guy that lives
to be a hundred and a guy that uh,
you know, smoked all the time and he was
fine until the day he died, you know,
whatever. But I know people that
I've seen their body deteriorate.
I've seen there, I've seen their face
start to like shrivel in cigarettes.
You know that weird thing you do when you,
when a guy's a chain smoker and you start
to see their face starts to shrivel in,
gets hardened to itself.
Right?
I look gray outside all the
time though to a leather face.
That beach face, you gotta be
outside smoking but just it's,
I, I know several people have died
because of the cigarettes. Several.
The first was a, a guy that I knew. Um,
well I guess I don't have any
relatives that died from it, but uh,
I knew a guy who was a at the pool hall,
used to hang out with.
He died slow cancer. Yeah, he died
slow. Got James Three guys there.
I knew three guys there that died from
cigarettes that had that smoke cigarettes
everyday chain smoked and
they got cancer and died.
Is anyone in your family
smoke? No, not anymore.
But my sister smoked for a little while
and my mom smoked for a little while ago.
You could probably smoke for a good 20
years if you want it. I'm not into it.
Thanks though. Just try
it. It's probably okay.
Probably like, I mean are you, you have
to admit you used to enjoy smoking. Oh,
I loved it. Are you kidding me and China.
I was thinking like I got the urge back.
Ooh. Cause everybody smokes over
there, right? Everyone gets folks,
maybe it's a pollution. So I was already
feeling it a little too. Just feel it.
You got, did you get close
to saying fuck it? No,
I was looking at people
with their cigarettes going,
do you think that you could smoke for
like a week and then not get hooked again?
They decide, no, I think I'm
to two cigarettes. I'm fully,
oh my goodness. One is still, I
can still like that was disgusting,
but you know what it might be discussing,
but if it does then it starts
going away through your body,
just moving and then the next day
you'd be like, yeah, I need one.
I really wish I understood addiction.
I had a guy on the year, Dr. Carl Hart,
who explained addictions to me,
but when you're talking to a guy super
smart and knows a lot about the human
body and the mechanisms of addiction,
and he's explaining to me,
I'm hearing the words he's saying and I
get what he's trying to explain to me,
but I totally understand the mechanisms
of how these addictions work.
I don't understand it,
but the way he was saying it was
that it's more mental than anything.
It's more people just, it's in their
mind, the actual physical addiction.
He said it's not that big of a deal.
Like the people that get their couches
and stuff that's usable couches. Yeah.
You know, those weird addictions, people
eat 30, the couch cushion out. Oh,
a little bit of time. I just haven't
seen that. I saw chicken was eating tape.
She was addicted to eat and tape. She
would pull the plastic tape, break it off,
but her mouth and start chewing it.
So there's nothing chemical to that.
That's just mental.
That's crazy person.
That's just a hundred percent
crazy something. But that's
also an addiction. Yeah.
That's what's weird about being a
person. It's, there's all, there's,
there's addictions of, yeah, there's
like addiction, stop it that are, uh,
like there could just compulsive they,
they,
because they were habit for whatever
reason. You just feel the need to do it.
Yeah. And a cigarette apparently
is one of, it's a big one.
He food's a big one for some folks.
It's the drive Thru that rush that you
get when you're not supposed to go to
that drive through, but
fuck it, let's do this.
And it's like you get an addiction
to had like a skydiving. Yeah.
Stopping an Arby's. Well, dude, I've had
that feeling. You've had that feeling too,
especially when you're drunk. Right. It's
just feel good to know you can get food.
Yeah. You're going to get
some delicious, delicious.
Remember when we still walked a carnies
right down the street from the store.
That's some of the worst shit you could
ever eat in your life. You know? So good.
So good. I had it like last year
again. Should never read it.
Every time I eat it, I was like, what
the fuck did I just do to my body?
No Food Pyramid where that's, yeah, you
get Chili fries on top of a Chili dog.
That's totally an addiction. Oh,
that place is an addictive place.
Those kinds of places are addictive
and great. Don't get me wrong.
I'm glad they exist. The race,
I would go there tomorrow.
But
there's a certain addiction to that,
that this is very peripheral cause you're
not doing it all day every day like
you can with cigarettes.
So I would imagine just the ritual
aspect of the tradition of the rituals.
What are the way bigger,
because you're doing it all day.
Something to do with your hands too.
Doing this all day.
It's nice to chew on cigarettes for years.
So when I'm sick of rights
the same six minutes,
it would've taken him to smoke it and
then throws it out and start to new one.
That's smart of him.
But then he started smoking again
and he starts smoking again.
But then one time they was a great story.
He threw one out and he started a new
one and he goes, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Toothpicks or three 99 for a hundred
that's so dice. Then he would worry
about how much money spending.
I'm given these jerk offs.
He's got to get a special brand cigarette
that he wasn't even smoking for like
five years. There is something
very calming about it though.
Like when you're stressed or
if you're like, oh yeah, no,
no cigarette real. There's a
real effect. Here's what's crazy.
That real effect is just that
you're addicted to cigarettes now.
Nicotine is calming. It's
not though. It's a stimulant.
Nicotine is more of a
stimulant. I'm pretty sure. I
don't think it has a calming.
It's also tomsie because you're like,
oh, now I don't need a cigarette anymore.
Well let's Google that because we live
in 2014 and I might be totally wrong,
but the way it was explained to me
and the way Dr. Hart describes it,
is it,
what's going on is you have this buildup
in his need to get it in your body.
Then when you get into your body,
so that when you're in a situation
where you're very stressed out,
you absolutely have
extraneous external stress.
You are members of the fact
that you need a cigarette,
but maybe it's also seems like the
same feeling as when you get serious,
when you do actually get
stressed. It's like, Oh,
this reminds me of the time I should
have cigarettes. Yeah. And again,
I think what we talked
about earlier that the writ,
the daily ritual aspect of a cigarette
must be incredibly strong because you do
it so often,
especially if you have a drink.
How many people tell you they only smoke
when they drink a lot of people, right?
What is that? You know,
you're doing something bad.
It's the same thing as eating the
carnies. You know, you're gonna,
you know you're doing something bad and
you're like, fuck it. It's a ritual.
When I get drunk I like to do that.
It's like the flavor of coffee and
cigarettes together is like the best two
ingredients that make the best pie ever.
Yeah. Nicotine. Nicotine is a stimulant.
It was good. This is the, um,
the actual explanation
of what nicotine is.
Nicotine is a potent boy.
Here we go. Sim Path though.
Simpatico mummy. Hectic. That's my
middle name. Paris in path though.
Mimetic alkaloid found in the nightshade
family of plants and is a stimulant
drug. Nightshade. That sounds cool.
That's why people like to smoke
cigarettes after they fuck sell does it.
Hot Sauce. I was like a GI.
Jane said, Nico Teen, Nick,
a [inaudible] receptor and agonist.
It's made from the roots and
accumulates in the leaves of plants,
which is a obviously tobacco plant.
I think some other plants have nicotine
a lot of words in there. I didn't know.
Yeah,
I think you can get nicotine from,
I want to say guarana or it
might be something differently.
I met some of the different kinds of
[inaudible] you ever have that? Um,
Asai that's what that is. While
we're on it. Berries. Yeah.
I'm pretty sure it was also he guarana
at Cornell. It's, it's spelled different.
Right? How's it spelled? [inaudible]
how you spell it? ACI is Nigeria.
I'm going to play Jeremy Cai. That's,
and the jury going to play Germany? Yeah.
There's a black eye on the Nigerian
team. I mean on the, on the, you know,
a lot on the German team.
Well, I, what's so funny,
I just wondered,
um,
this Asa II stuff is so delicious,
but apparently when you get it in Brazil,
you get like the pure form event and a
lot of times what we get has a lot of
sugar in it.
Wonder who's got the best onsite,
but it's a so I'm wrong. It's not that
other fruit. What did I say it was?
What did I think it was?
Guarana Guarana I think guarana is a
totally different thing. Oh yeah, I know,
but it's a guarana is some sort of
stimulant. Go around is like caffeine.
You ever heard of that shit? That soda,
that Brazilian soda? I forbid a child.
You never had that green, that
green. Oh son. You missing out.
If you're going to go to Fogo de Chao
and have the full Brazilian experience,
you've got to get one of those Guarana
so sodas, I'm gonna go back to Brazil.
So go there or does though.
Yeah,
it sounds they have real photos.
They have the original photos in Rio.
Chicken hearts.
Yeah.
They have chicken hearts and Oregon's
and they love to eat like that. Man.
Those people love to eat like
that core. Ron Has Caffeine. Yes,
it does. Okay. Yeah, so that
stuff has caffeine in it.
That's what I was getting confused with.
So go Ron.
I'm pretty sure as it totally
different thing. I'll say. Yeah.
It doesn't even look like that.
I Sayi is those berries.
Anyway, the important thing is
keep smoking because it stimulates.
You don't listen to these guys. They're
fucking with you, man. Don't do it.
I wonder how many people as we talked
about cigarettes at how bad they were,
got the urge and lit up. I'm
sure they did. They probably,
they're smoking right now. At least
sub cursing us. You know what? I wish,
I wish I never smoked my whole life
and now my 40th birthday I would start
smoking and he just,
cause who cares?
You know by the time you turn 40 who
cares if you get cancer? Oh my God,
you're so retarded. Would it be Ben,
why wouldn't it be when you're 43 okay.
I wonder about you sometimes.
Maybe that fucking computer sitting in
front of computer editing, just cooked.
You ever think of that like radiation
and you're shit's not good for you.
Maybe you can do it from a
distance with a remote control or
dictate to things and you start looking
at things and overplaying stuff over and
over and over like three hours
in a row and you're just looking,
it's like a sign of being really in
love with what you're doing and we just
really connected. You're obsessed
with your work? Yeah. Come on man.
You know that when you release those
really good ones and you got awesome
response online from people that just work
but universally on that message board,
people talking about how great
your video editing skills.
Where I about it of those nights
where you're like, oh I'm sure. Yeah
they actually say that that is what's
happening. It's cooking your tear ducts.
Wow. Really? So there's something about
it like it dries out your tear ducts,
it's really bad for you.
I still cry.
Well I got a pair of
glasses and they're yellow.
They're supposed to cut down on the
glare. It's like less, less intrusive.
It's like shooting glasses.
They look just like this type of
glasses you wear on the range.
Cause like looking through
yellow is supposed to be like,
remember have those stupid fucking
commercials for those cheap
ass sunglasses. Steet glasses.
They're the best son goes around these.
What do you think of these
things so much clear. Wow. Yeah,
it's a girl wears them
and Tom, but really? Yeah.
Well those are the ones that you're
supposed to look at when you look at you
like that crazy vision and wraps around
my normal spectacles that God wants to.
There's a little window
on the side. Listen, Ari,
you got nothing to say to that guy.
Get Him.
What do you and him got
to talk about your next,
you're on a bus next to each other for
five hours. What do you do for a living?
I'm just the comic. Uh, where'd
you get those glasses? Oh,
these are my HD wrap arounds
as seen on TV. Oh really?
He's also as even your order from TV,
you allow me to see you in a
totally different light. Like what?
We're kind of like Jew.
You can see the hearts.
What is it like being a jail? Rawr.
What is it like? My favorite question.
My favorite stupid
question to ask somebody.
What is it like to whatever
you'd like to be fucking funny.
It's like eight.
What's it like to have those beautiful
wrap around yellow sunglasses?
It's like not having them, but
it's way better than that. Yeah.
People will say some weird shit to
people sometimes. What's it like? Yeah,
it must be nice.
You like what's like drinking a coca cola,
which you'd like to have him for?
What? Her brother? Her brother Ha.
What's it like? I don't know what it's
like to have him for her brother. Yeah.
It's like we're just lucky to
have her phone mom. Huh? Fuck Bro.
I guess the experiences, uh, yeah.
People say douchey things
like on the sneak tip,
they can see Douchey Shit
like that where you don't,
you're not supposed to get mad at them,
but you're allowed to anyway. It's like,
what the fuck you doing? Going nowhere.
You're wasting everyone's time.
What's it like to have her for a mom?
What the fuck?
I'm kind of questioning you
asking me bitch. Like that's
some weird person, right?
That's a person who's not nice.
They're being douchey with you.
Fuck come right.
Pac Sun Shit.
Did you follow that story about that
kidnapping of the kid that they found in
the hell?
Was that about which kit?
It's very suspect. Right. What
happened? Interviewed the Guy.
The father too. I guess last night I
didn't watch it, but I heard it was a,
you're trying to tell me that you didn't
look in the basement for your son and
he was in there for 11 days.
Is that what you're trying to tell me
sir and wasn't he like I just dead?
Huh? He was just trapped
in there. He was hiding.
Oh he apparently the official
story. He died. No, no,
he's alive. They went looking
for him for like 11 days.
The kid was in the basement the whole
time hiding behind some chuck dungeon.
He decided to make himself like a
little house back there. We had food.
There's clothes. Yeah. Obviously
there's something wrong,
you know?
I mean that doesn't seem like a normal
kid wants to be around their parents.
Right. You know, she just
don't usually want to hide.
These must be much more
than it. I mean 11 days. Oh,
I don't want any of this jacket. That's
no way because some kid hides for level,
something's wrong. Whatever
it is. Whoever did something,
it seems like something's wrong.
How many people are out there like
that that we don't know about?
What percentage of the population is
in some terrible place like that where
they're trying to hide from their parents
or they're trying to hide from someone
in their family or someone they are
close to what percentage it is Detroit,
Michigan to kids.
11 he might just have a girlfriend.
He's fucking in a basement somewhere.
That's true.
It'd be banging in the basement.
I don't think so though because they
said they found them so low back there.
Maybe decided to go on an
epic masturbation app when
they found him. I Dunno.
It's full. We had food, good
food down there. He was hiding,
but there was blood that there
was found like on rags and stuff.
There's a lot of really weird and
questions about this whole boy.
I didn't hear about that part yet.
Blood, they could be right, but girls do.
Girls get their period now 11
in Detroit. They do. They do.
I heard the choice becoming the
metal. So because of the metal, um,
don't whoever said that, tell him to
go. Fuck. Artists are moving in there.
Changing up. Listen, I hope that happens.
We were just there a little while ago.
Yeah, there's, it's, there's houses there.
There are $500
herselves in 20 years I've gotten a
house for $10 that you didn't do it.
Why didn't you buy a hundred at $10?
All due respect to kid rock and M and M.
I'm not moving to fucking Detroit. I'm
not buying property there. It's just,
it went bad.
I hope it goes back but it went bad.
What are they going to do suddenly
build new plants there? Well listen,
the folks that are there,
I definitely think there's like an artist
community there and there's a lot of
cool, we met a lot of cool people
that live there. No doubt about it.
But I'm saying if you were trying to
like invest in something that you thought
would definitely like you think you're
stealing money and I was going to take a
look, it's going to take a lot of
work to bring it out right back then.
Detroit people are cool as fuck though,
man. I enjoyed hanging out there.
People were super nice, but I felt
bad. We were on this river, um,
where uh, these people were fishing and
I was like, this water is not clean.
This is dirty water. And they were like,
yeah, it is. And the other, just like,
it's one of the most,
the area around Zog islands when the
most polluted areas in the country. Wow.
And these people were fishing it
and I was like, man, I mean, how,
I don't know if they're
testing these fish.
I don't know if people
are just eating them.
There were Chinese people fishing in
those fucking dirty. Then it was like,
what are you doing it when the residents
were like, what are you doing? They just,
they need food, man. That's what
it is. You know, you might have a,
a fish that's not so good, but at
least you're not hungry. You know,
you cook it up. Good Shit if
you're smoking cigarettes already,
you know, what a difference does it
make if you eat a fucking metallic fish,
some fish loaded up with this has it
polluted of heavy metal solutions.
Apparently they checked a fish that
they caught outside of Fukushima. Yeah.
And it was fine and it was
one of the fish. It was a,
this is science guy who debunks a
lot of the myths about, you know,
climate change and disasters and all
sorts of like when he's like very,
very strict, very, um, very,
very concise with his, uh, you know,
like whether it's politically correct
or not very scientific about his, um,
explanations for these things.
And he was explaining to,
this is a fish that is indigenous
to this area. It doesn't migrate.
She's a fish that's been sucking in
that water filled with radiation.
It's only like a mile off the coast.
I think it was less than a mile.
And you can eat it. And he's
like, these fish are fine. Like,
you don't have to worry about
the fish and stuff like that.
They have caught fish that have an
elevated amount of radiation in it.
And this is what's been really
fascinating about Fukushima. Obviously,
I'm a fucking idiot.
So when you're listening to me,
anything that I say that might
sound tricky, Google it. What's,
what's fascinating about this is that
it's opened me up to paying attention to
how many different things have radiation.
Like there was an article the other day
that said Grand Central Station has more
radiation naturally occurring
because of all that stone,
all that marble that they have
inside of their marble. Ha.
It gives off a certain amount of
natural radiation and it radiates.
And there's more radiation inside that
giant train station then is allowable at
a nuclear power plant for
workers. Rarely, yes. Wow. Wow.
But it's natural radiation. So
it's like when you, I don't know,
I don't understand that. That's where she
gets weird. But when you're on a plane,
you're taking megadoses.
We had ensign in UAE who
lives in Japan and Ensign. Uh,
he does a lot of relief work
for people have been Fukushima,
trying to help people and spread the word
about how bad the situation is and how
many displaced people were up there.
He said that he brought his
Geiger counter with him.
He brings the guy and he brought in a
plane. They said when you were in a plane,
it's like the same as when you're in
Fukushima. It's, it's fucking terrible.
My Dad said that you could actually
hang out there for a couple of hours and
you'll be fine. So, so if you find
a fish that's like a mile off shore,
that fish is probably not just hanging
out at that exact location for, you know,
the whole time it probably just swam
there, got caught and you know, so I,
it's probably safe enough to eat.
No, but that is, fish
wasn't a migratory fish.
That was one of the reasons
why it was significant.
I think it's hard to put in our stupid
little heads how big the fucking ocean is.
Pretty big. Yeah, it's hard. It's so big.
It's bigger than then the country.
The continent, yeah. It's silly.
If you look at what the Pacific Ocean
looks like and you look at the constant in
North America, we're like, it's a little
tiny thing in there. We don't have,
we don't show the whole thing on the map
because there's not enough room to show
the whole thing on the map. Oh really?
I mean short of, I mean look, you,
you don't really get it. You don't
get it. There's no way you get it.
The only way you get it, fine Australia
fine. Just go out there and find it.
It's like fucking, they don't
understand or it could be so much water.
You can't see an end to the left.
You can see an end to the right.
You can't see an end to head and
you can't see an end behind you.
There's everywhere you look is just
water like a pie and you, yeah,
and you better have a fucking
good one of them. I'm fine. Yeah.
That's the stuff we were
going to get back to it.
Exactly. There was a
part in life, the play,
I just watched it in
three d the other day,
but there was a part in it where the
tiger made this crazy face right before he
was about to pee on the,
on the main character.
And it was so trippy that it was made
me wonder why they threw it in there.
Like it was very unrealistic.
And you were saying that you thought
that movie kind of felt unrealistic,
the tiger.
Well it was completely unrealistic as
far as the dynamic of the relationship
between the guy and the tiger.
The fact that they fought over food,
the fact that he beat the tiger back
and he was on a boat. I mean that,
that I can go so far
if he had super powers,
he was wolverine or something like that.
You, you, you understood the
yeah, explained all that to
happen. No, he's hallucinating.
But during the movie I'm like, this is
just pissing me off. Cause too much.
When, when he was trying to get up that
ladder and he wouldn't let him in the
[inaudible]
boat, man, that was
some deep shit eat shit.
But the problem is that's my only
problem with it is the unreal.
I mean, I shouldn't have a problem
with it if it's just a dream. Right.
But the unrealistic movement of the
cat that was driving me fucking crazy
because without that, the whole movie
does not exist. It doesn't work.
It's just special bugs movie. Yeah,
because they all use a slow mo.
Did you see that one? Like this is, wow,
this is just a commercial for that camera.
You can't do that. Hey, did
you like Godzilla? I'm going
to guess. Yes. Only the end.
I love the end. What was the end
when he killed that monster? Yeah.
Spoiler alert. No, you can display this.
Say Spoiler to get a limited amount of
time and then it's like go fuck yourself.
Ample opportunity to say somebody
who's a soup bowl winner the next day.
Y'All can give away star wars at
some point. That's a shitty movie.
Do you have a year to watch it?
It wasn't that shitty.
Some people,
it's like the hipster thing,
just so dumb. Even breaking bad was
like, oh, like unpleasant in it. Well,
he'll do anything good.
He's die storyline in there.
Almost said what happens to them. Say
it all has problems. No, don't do that.
Listen, it was a decent special
effects movie and Godzilla.
Godzilla was most certainly no spoilers,
no spoilers.
Most certainly the best Godzilla of
all time. Without a doubt. You didn't.
The CGI is mind the part where he got,
hey,
easy buried under that building and then
all of a sudden he was up and fighting
again and then the next thing he was
back to buried under that building.
Nobody likes guys getting knocked out
with like pistols in the movie and you're
getting up and then duking their way out
of a bar. Nobody likes him more than me.
It's my, those are my favorites. So
unrealistic. I'm saying not getting up,
being buried under a building,
suddenly fighting the second my throat
guy and then back to buried under the
building as if he'd never
had gotten out of it. Yeah,
ridiculous. Yeah, like just
terrible editing. That really
happens. Yeah. He got out.
I was like, wait, what's happening?
There was no consistency.
They just edited it wrong. When,
how about the dude? Yeah. Horrible.
The dude had like the worst luck of
all time, but yet the best luck. Yeah.
It was all the character.
Like all these terrible things keep
happening and yet he's just wanting,
but Godzilla looked awesome.
What I loved about Godzilla was the face.
It was incredible.
I was gonna ask you,
Tony said that he hated it because the
face was really round and he looked very
Japanese and cutesy, cutesy. Know what,
I don't want to, Tony's an evil man.
I think that was Tony.
I said that,
I'm pretty sure he's the one that
said he looks Japanese and evil.
Tony Hinchcliffe cutesy, cutesy.
I will go with Qsu. Yeah,
Tony Hinchcliffe. Um, I don't know why
he was thinking about it. Looking cutesy.
I thought God's all looked awesome.
It looked pretty cool.
I had no problem with the
look. I just loved the movie,
felt it felt like a bunch of Hollywood
people. Made it like interim afternoon.
We'll just felt like when you have,
uh, an idea that's that high concept,
you can run into,
cut the shit moments.
You could run into a bunch of cut the
shit moments and there was just too many
of them were your money.
Yeah.
I mean you could get away with
doing a movie like 28 days later.
Obviously there's completely
different types of movie,
but there was no cut the shit
move moments in that movie.
That movie was hard fucking quarters
one dragged you into it. Really?
What was one when he's in the
boiler work, oh come on. It's
probably more what was the spoiler?
So he goes to that compound,
right? With all the army people they turn
cause that's how I like it. Realistic.
That's what humans would
do. Right. It's a, you know,
not pick Kelsey or whatever, someone's
view of the world. But um, no.
Who was that director? Kubrick.
Kubrick. Yeah. He would always like,
humans will just devolve to animals.
Pretty much trigger white society.
So that's fine. But then he like
releases like the ones I'll be into the,
they were keeping, but he's like
suddenly an expert with weapons.
All the whole movie's like trying to
figure out what's happening. I love that.
That'd be no clue. He's never going to
try to find a cure. He's not that special.
And then suddenly he's just got,
he's really awesome with a
machine gun out of nowhere. No.
How long had he been hanging
out with those resisters?
It was too fast. Too fast.
Cause you only it the only moment.
Everything else is great.
What if you had a background in
military or some shit? Like okay,
that makes sense.
That's very cliche though.
The loan guy who had a
background in the military,
he's a loner fucking same shit. Carl
has been using a gun. He's fucking six.
I it shoot somebody over his
father's shoulder have like ars.
He's older now shooting a lot of zombies.
You get good at shit like that.
Kids are good at video games in
that world is awesome at guns.
I feel bad for Carl because he
has zero chance of getting laid.
This no pussy for Carl [inaudible].
He's already wandering around
shooting fucking shooting zombies.
There's no pussy. He's like some older
checks that might eventually take them.
Would you, I'm going to change
the extent the question,
how long until you would, um, once
you heard about cutting off the arms,
the zombies and like, fuck man, fuck one.
I would worry that, look dude, I
wouldn't fuck someone with aids.
Imagine the fucking,
someone with a Zombie pack.
It's like people with Aids
live a lot longer than zombies.
People with AIDS look
way better than zombies.
They just need some fucking medication.
There's modern drugs. Okay, you can,
but I wouldn't do that. Would you
fuck a guy who had a, who had aids?
No. What about girls? Of course not. No,
of course not.
So why would you fuck a Zombie?
Because there's nobody else to fuck.
Oh fuck dude.
You wouldn't even if there was
nowhere else to fuck hold on its back.
It would if there was no one else.
Oh yeah, maybe just fun. Lisbon.
But you'd have a progress the,
but we'd have a problem.
He'd still feel like a
rapist. You imagined it holds
it. Some girls Zombie down,
she's screaming and national and you're
trying to fucker, what'd it feel?
Terrible. If it starts screaming at
different way. You feel that, oh,
what if you fucked him and they came back
to life. Thank you. I couldn't tell you,
but that was a secret.
I knew I had to fuck me.
You can imagine about a cure that
none of you are going to believe
a prince and a frog heloc. You the
girl had a kiss the frog, right?
The guy's got a fuck the Zombie and
pretend she comes back to like my fucking
arms off asshole. I'm
so sorry. I didn't know.
I thought you were never coming back.
That's a great idea for a movie and
everyone just starts fucking zombies and
then like you have to
fuck the little ones too,
just so that becomes one of the
bite you while you're doing it.
It's like fuck that. I got
a target. You'll be calling
them rape the young debt.
That would be the end all raping on
dead through the, yeah, the whole,
all three of the movie
would be death metal.
Just guys checking doors down.
Holden zombies down.
Hail ass is bobbing up and down.
Male and female zombies
just to interracial intergen
under orgy of fucking dead
people as they come back till they get,
they got to start fucking wherever zombies
are left to go back to the compound.
Dude's got a fucking oil drum fill
of Viagra. I got to fight the fight
for the bang on future imagined.
It's like between fucking and biting like
it's a race between the fuckers in the
biters cause the biters would fuck you
back a little bit. They bite you back.
Then the fuckers in the I am of fellow.
Could you imagine if the only way that
you could get them to come back is to
fuck them?
Fuck everybody.
He didn't have to fuck your enemies
because you would wouldn't want him being
zombies and eating your family.
So there'd be a fuck him to come up with
a boner to fuck. Fuck. You're a landlord.
That annoying lady lives down the block.
The fucking yappy poodle.
That bitch turn into a Zombie.
You gotta fuck fucker.
Zombies like making it really hard
for you to like I got this one.
Everybody would be rushing
to yoga mat places. God.
How long till zombies? How long
until it triggers? Oh yeah.
Whoever got locked in the zone in the,
in the yoga, whatever it happened there.
If you can get to a yoga mat,
most likely you're going to have some
hot chasing shapes on bare Assamese and
that might kind of be a freak or the
farts have stayed in there for too long
with that.
Somby just completely gave into you.
What does the psalm he started backing up
on? Your ticket was a female yoga Toby.
She started backing up on your tank. She
was really into it. I'm like, Holy Shit.
But she's still, he reaches back the
closet. Yes sir. You got to hold of wrist,
but she's, she's back in India. Yeah.
What'd you go to yoga first and with the
youngest the first place I go if I was
on a mission to save the world at first.
But
yeah,
but you see it's a race between if you
could fuck them before they can bite you
or their friend's bite you.
Right.
So you can't go into places like a
fucking Korean barbecue solo plus eat.
You don't come back at all. It was a good
point. You might kill you. You only come,
you only turn into one of them
if they bite you a little.
If they bite you a little, get a
little blood on you. I come fast.
So I won't be worried. How cause that'd
be making an army of real quick. I know.
I don't think so.
I think you need to fill them up.
I think like every time you come inside
of them to get like a little less Zombie.
Oh,
more human down for like weeks.
Chain him up in your basement,
Bang them.
But then the problem would be both get
addicted to having sex in that way.
Once you become a normal person, how long
have you get hard? Every time you hear
boner? Yeah. Maybe.
Maybe just automatically here that you
hold the chicks hands behind her back.
She was like, what the fuck? I don't like
this. Ari. Cut The shit. Oh sorry. Sorry.
It's just we're playing raped.
Zombie.
What'd be gross that we'd
all come back to life.
But half of them would be
like missing like chunks.
[inaudible] fine.
So she's got no lips.
She's a sweet girl.
She draws pictures of
the things she wants.
I can walk down with your
hold until that hand too much.
It's just as bad for it's breaks
off now they're a regular person.
They start crying and looking at
this stubs. That's why is that?
That's the thing that people
are constantly worried about,
the constantly worried
about the Zombie apocalypse.
That's like a recurring theme cause
maybes fucking Bible. Is that what it is?
Oh, I don't know. There's no such
thing as zombies in the Bible,
but do you think it's because people
worry that it's so loosely put together,
society so loosely put together is
really become that easily. Just fuck up.
Something go wrong.
What would make it go wrong?
That some fucking disease it
gives us rabies or something.
You think of things like that,
like Whoa, don't go near that.
Squares with 12 monkeys came out.
I was like a real man.
That shit's real is they have toxins
that can like get with everybody.
That was a terrifying movie. There's a
lot of those movies. Those Apocalypto
apocalyptic movies aren't there, so it's
fine. Fuck load of a man. 28 days later,
they're 28 weeks and that was 20 days
later. Yes. There was a something.
They a chimp disease, right?
They manufactured it and
then it got into people out.
God Damn, that was a good Zombie movie.
They were fast as fuck. Like, oh wow.
They really fast.
We pet her.
I don't know how the fuck do went
back to slow zombies after that.
28 days later would be 10 times more epic
if those motherfuckers were fast rage.
Could you imagine if those motherfuckers
were fast, that movie would be,
that show would be so different running
after it was passed. I don't know if it,
you could do it.
I mean,
maybe one of the elements in
being able to construct these,
these stories that take place over long
periods of time is that the zombies
can't be the biggest threat because
if they're not the biggest threat,
then people sort of become
the biggest threat. Right,
because that show is a show about the
zombies are sort of periphery at this
point.
Like what the show's really all about
is people like turning on people walking
dead, right. That's what it's all
about is obviously like a, it's just,
it's like a speed bump. They should avoid
that thing. It should be nothing. Like,
I used to go crazy when I watched that
show when they were all at the prison and
they were all outside. I'm like, why
aren't you killing them? Like Wah.
And then one day became a problem.
Like what? Either right there,
they're pressed up against the cage.
Occasionally you'd see them kill them,
but there were days on end without their
plant tomatoes because there's because
outside of the fence you mean there's,
there's millions of them.
It's just fucking kill him every
day. That's what you do today, dude.
That's what you do today
is to catch them on fire.
You know like this Puerto like hot
lava. That's too, that's too hard.
Why don't you do that? We just
stabbing the head, stabbed in the head.
It takes five seconds to look out
for today. That's your workout. What?
There was so many, you could just mowed
them all down and like big portions.
That's you're taking the
lazy way. You don't want a
goddamn exercise. I'm talking,
I'm thinking like one of those miners
acts as well as pick axes and he's just
doing like Kettlebell exercises.
Just smashing these zombies are
things in the head. Yeah, the switch.
You got to go to a lot of lefties cause
you don't want to imbalance your back.
Do you think you could do that?
Could you? Even if it was a Zombie,
because I think I'd be back to like,
oh you talking about do that right now.
If it was a girl crew zombies,
I wouldn't need any preparation.
There are zombies up against the fence.
You wouldn't even take me five seconds
to stab the first Zombie in the head.
If you gave me a nice big sword type
thing and there was zombies and I had to
stab him, I would immediately
start stabbings on. Huh?
You would see like the human element,
like a little necklace that you're like,
oh I that neck. Nope. Nope. Right.
Your brain, that's not a little kid.
That's monster off with his head. Yeah,
they had that. I always have that one.
So somebody sees their
kid. Yeah, whatever.
Not me like stabby stabby I
know how to get over things.
That's
fucked up.
That was the most fucked up part of that
show where guys have like kill their
wives and shit and killed their
family members. Killed her daughters.
That's tough. The one that God kept his
door locked up. He thought she was sick.
I kept like talking to all the
time. Ooh, that, yeah, that is dark.
Dark would be an example of,
it wouldn't be that example that you're
very specific scenario would definitely
take place with a lot of people.
There would be too hard for them to take
and also they would also hope that one
day there'll be a cure. Yeah.
Yeah. Then we could like say it,
but there's carrying this
threat around all the time.
I wonder if you could have the same
show with that 28 days later style.
Well I was just, people survive
in this Lumbees much faster.
But would the stories be the same?
Because it seems like they would be the
Zombie to be a way bigger threat. Yeah.
They were on you at any time
and then it's over. Yeah,
they were way bigger threat.
He couldn't have as many like
relationships with people that go bad.
You wouldn't really get to that.
You'd just be scrambling for survival
and these things that I'm fucking chasing
after you full clip with
crazy bloodshot eyes.
Remember that I was 28 weeks later. It
was pretty good too. I was pretty good.
Wasn't as good, but it's
pretty God damn good. Pretty
God damn good. Yeah. That's a,
that's a realistic monster
scenario. Not like Godzilla. Oh,
there's something that's on
the ocean. It's been there
the whole time waiting. Oh,
get the fuck outta here.
We tried to kill it during World War II.
They were trying to kill it. That's what
the nuclear bomb, they weren't tests.
They were trying to kill somebody.
It's all so badly.
You dummy.
You can watch the animated Gif online.
Those tests that they did in the South
Pacific, they weren't shooting Godzilla.
You can't relate to his truck's movie.
They did that in the x meant to what?
They said that Kennedy was a mutant bitch.
Stop.
How do you think one man got
shot three times? One bullet.
He was trying to curve the bullet
of white bitch. Stop you guys.
I can't believe you
left that in the script.
That's one of the summer.
You see the been in the middle.
You need to take it to a
board of people who look,
we will watch this and tell
you like what's ridiculous.
We're all sitting around smoking. Why
would he do that? Why would he do that?
Do that as a service desk squad movie,
We watch a movie idea. We'll sit down,
watch a movie together and then give
them feedback, but it's gotta be,
fuck you asshole. Worthless already.
But we'll give you honest feedback.
We won't like, we'll, we'll cuss in our
feedback. Probably will be like that.
That was fucking stupid. I would never
do that. You know what they would need?
They would need something where you
would agree to not talk about it.
If it was really bad, they would,
they would need that. Don't move.
He's going to suck when there's no uh,
critical reviews because they don't
put it before the critics. Look,
you guys got a it and they all know it.
So like when you see no
ratings on rotten tomatoes,
avoid that moved the day before they
know it's a piece of shit. Not even,
those people are diluted enough
to think people will like this.
This also weird movies
that like they don't
for like years, they like sit on the shelf
and then like, do you remember Antonio,
Ben Dennis, the 13th warrior.
Do you remember that?
It was originally called
like the eater of the dead.
It was a god who was the county,
but Darris he's just chilling,
man. He got a lot of money just
enjoying himself. Eating cartoons,
eating pineapples and drinking.
Margarita isn't shit eaters of the dead.
The 13th Warrior 6.6 yeah.
It was one of those movies that
took a long time to come out.
It was a Michael Crighton
book. Oh, well yeah.
I think I read it.
Either I read it or I started to,
I think I started to read it,
but I never actually read it,
but it's from a long time ago. The
book was written 1976 really? Yeah.
The book is like way more involved
though and much more like much creepier
books. They're always get it
better. Well, they do so rare.
They do better than the
San Antonio Banderas movie.
It was way over budget apparently. Oh
yeah. Yeah. How did it go over budget?
They'd only made 62 like,
why am I paying for all that?
This is how much money they lost.
It made 62 million,
but the budget was more than a hundred
million. Wow. Oh Gee. Wow, wow.
You know like stupid. Is that I
Frankenstein? Maybe. Oh my God,
you could make that. Who
said you can make it. Dot.
Frankenstein said you could make that.
Could you imagine if you sit down with
the guys who wanted to make time to go,
women Wayman.
What you having a sexy Frankenstein?
Did you just tell me you having a
sexy Frankenstein and he's like, Oh,
I could've swore I could have
sworn I walked in this office.
A Mom told me you wanted me to
invest movie and a sexy Frankenstein.
I did not. I say it. Listen,
listen, listen, listen.
This is what we got. We got,
we got fucking vampires.
Vampires are sexy. Gone to go.
What's the difference in a
vampire and Frankenstein alive?
Now that we're bolt debt,
Frankenstein is alive,
so a sexy Frankenstein who can pull
it off? I'll tell you what's his name?
Was it Aaron Eckhart? That's who can pull
it off. That is our sexy Frankenstein.
This is what, this is what we've been
missing. Ari, this was a, this is off.
I could twilight, so wait, he's not going
to like be like a big zombie anymore.
It's not going to be a big no, no. He's
beautiful. He's delicious. He talks well.
It looks at a guy who's been in a
rough street fight with the box cutter.
It's clearly not fricking stuff.
Hey, he's, he would fucking,
Dracula wasn't even allowed to go in the
sun, but the Edward Guy just sparkled.
Okay. You can change the rules.
It's, it's part of fiction.
While I was at Seattle's overcast. Is that
how they got rid of that? I don't know.
I think that sets the don't put
the V. Yeah, that's what it was.
That's why he went up there.
They went to Pacific northwest because
that's why they moved up. Never.
The Sun never comes out, but when it does
come out and they glisten. Oh really?
Yeah. Die like a real fucking
vampire. They changed the rules.
That's why it's bullshit.
It's why pull up without us
getting pulled off of Youtube.
I don't know if it's possible,
but see if you could pull up video
of Frankenstein with no volume.
Don't put any volume on it and let's just
mock how it looks. Won't matter Jamie.
They'll still pull it. All right.
Fuck it then don't do it. Is this,
look at it for yourself.
You know when you do,
we need to set it up on that thing so
we can watch it without it being four k
special dot. Come to me. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. We'll do that from now on.
There's no copper advise in China. Is this
new Frankenstein? Like the same story?
Like as he does he claim please.
Winged creatures making shit up.
They're making shit up. I think it was
like, oh fuck no sparkles when he goes up,
it's bullshit. It's all
bullshit. He's just,
and he's smoldering meanwhile. Oh, how
the fuck is that guy still in class?
You imagine your thousand years old,
you'd keep going to class cause you don't
want to give anybody suspicious. Oh,
when did Columbus discover? Oh yeah, I
was alive back then. 40 minutes. Right.
And he was actually, this is like
the Spanish flu that killed him,
which was like thinking in 19
hundreds killed to Edward. Oh really?
From twilight until he died. Spanish
flu, big Spanish flu and it got killed.
The vampire and the vampire, he got
vampired right around the same time.
That's how I stayed alive forever. Uh,
same time back in the Spanish flu days.
Oh, okay. So he's always around
for like 100 years or so.
She's old enough to know that he
shouldn't be in high school anymore. Yeah.
Fucking idiot.
Trying to pretend.
It's like the ideas that he
died when he was in high school.
So we keep me in high school forever.
No. Why? How much does grow a beard?
He's older than I look. Yeah.
Just say I look young for my age.
Hey, don't doubt it. That was
something that I read today online. Um,
where was showing how many Asian
women could be like almost 50.
And they look like the 20 year old.
Is that really true?
You just got back from Japan. They
look for the look younger. Not 20,
but it looks super young. Like 50 looks
like 30. Let's say that. Wow. Yeah.
They stay in shape. Low Fat, low fat,
low sugar diets, low sugar diets,
and they stay in shape.
You have to walk around a lot,
at least in the few cities I went to.
Hmm.
I know a couple of girls that are there.
Their skin looks good.
45 and I mean they look pretty sexy.
Yeah. Asian girls keep it for a while. Oh
yeah. Why is that you think? I don't know.
I think it's just better genetics
that way. Their food, more alien DNA.
Just that the time, that's all.
It's just the type that stays young.
Longer Jews to have the kind
that makes you smarter. Okay.
Asians have the kind that makes it look,
how did black don't crack without,
without at risk of sounding really
racist. Yeah. Although I'm not,
I start recording now.
If you look at all the different races,
obviously this some sort of biological
explanation for this,
but how the fuck did so many Asian
people have such similar features?
How the fuck did so many African
people have similar features? I mean,
it's amazing.
It's amazing when you look around and
how many Chinese people have black hair
and similar skin tone.
How many black people have that hair and
similar skin tone? You know, how many,
how many, I mean it's amazing. It
was whites have a variety. Well,
people who are of mixed race,
you know, like, like my family,
a lot of it comes from Sicily.
And you remember that scene from uh Huh.
You're a true romance.
The Moore's the more,
but I think the Moore's were
Sephardic people. I'm not sure.
I was like Morocco dogs. So black. I'll
show, I'll Shitzu's look like shit soon.
There's all white people like months
right now. Here's what's weird.
Cause breeds of dogs were engineered.
That's why it's crazy.
Breeds of dogs originally were all wolves.
All dogs.
Where at one point in time who knows
how many thousands of years ago,
they don't have no idea. Like when
people started domesticating dogs,
but they assume that it was right around
the time civilization was invented
whenever and that's my
breeds became a thing. Yeah.
It's like 10,000 years of breeding.
That's where you're looking
at when you look at a Shitzu.
When you look at the Husky, when you look
at a wolf there, it's the same animal.
Wow. It started off the
same animal. Like what dog?
That's it. That's through all.
They all come from wolves,
which is the weirdest thing. English
bulldog, a wolf who was like,
let's get the two coolest Wolfe's.
Well,
they had an episode
about it on the cosmos.
It was really fascinating that the
cosmos show, if you watch that. No,
I've got ground. That's good. So good.
And it pisses off religious people.
Oh my goodness. Well,
we want, we want the uh,
whatever theory explained to and
that people put signs and he goes,
why would I include that?
There's no scientific basis for,
what are you talking about? We're talking
about science of him. Yeah. He's awesome.
He's awesome.
It's fun talking about that.
What happened was apparently
according to the cosmos,
is that some wolves got friendly with
people because the people would feed them
and then they kept coming around
to people would feed them.
They developed a relationship,
but then those wolves to chase off
the other wolves and then they,
they only bread with the wolves that
were friendly and nice wolves. Yeah.
Those wolves eventually became dogs.
Wow.
Over who knows how many thousands
of years. Selective breeding,
bringing certain dogs that wolves it
behaving certain ways together. I mean,
I don't know how many generations it
took to do it every new there. But yeah,
that's what she, that's a human
service when human breeding. Yup.
That's what we were like,
just like my new theory about
why black people are late. Yeah.
So you've heard about black people
time and how they just, they're late.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
A racial stereotype.
I've never been heard it.
If you haven't heard now you heard,
I never say anything bad
about black people calling.
John Barrett says it's only
one race. The human race. Um,
cause when you were slaves
you time didn't matter at all.
What about Jamaicans?
They're on time.
I think they were slaves. It's a
poor example. Any black people over?
What about Africans? Actual Africans?
Yeah. They're hard working people.
Some of the hardest working people
you'll ever hire or African Africans.
Those are the drug dealers in and uh,
uh,
Beijing and Hong Kong u ratting them
out on, on the podcast. It's like that.
All the black people, you're ratting
them out. I guess so. How dare you?
Because a race dude,
you shouldn't do that because I bet the
Chinese authorities had no idea. I know.
I bet it was a complete
mystery cracked by Ari.
Shift fear on the Joe Rogan podcast.
Yeah,
she explained and math.
Mathematics.
If they got angry and they
started going after you,
this is something that you would think
about your, you're eating lots of meat.
Like my weight. Too much pot. If you ate
way too much pot cook, you're like, why
did I give you were drug dealers?
What the fuck? I'm such an idiot.
Oh my God. What was I thinking? Oh my God,
I ratted out all the drug dealers.
The guy from the podcast,
I saw your podcast, your
tickets. You want drugs from me.
I would love, so he might've said that
shit dude. You'd be tripping. No, no, no,
no. That would kill you. Oh
yeah, I serve you. That's true.
That's worse than not telling you. How
many weeks were you over there? Uh,
two and a half. And you, you were in
China, you were in Singapore? No. No.
Did you go to Africa?
South America and out a few cities around
their Beijing and then a and then Hong
Kong. So what was the biggest
city out of the Shanghai?
Shanghai shoots once he 4 million on
black God and one of the New York 24
million, right? Yeah. Manhattan has nine,
but I mean like New York stuffed in there.
Normally stuffed in there after. There's
a few places with like one story. Thanks.
But not much. Everything's just tall
buildings because La is 20 million people.
But the good news is they're flat out.
The flattened down I think
alleviates a little bit of pressure.
I was completely flat, so, but
it's low like stories and stuff.
Oh, all short buildings? No,
I'd say actually the ground
is flat so you could bike.
Oh, okay. That's not what I meant.
I meant that they will stack
on top of each other. Yeah, no,
they have a hundred stores. Yeah. See
that's the difference in New York and La.
New York doesn't really
have those. Yeah. Excuse me.
La doesn't really have the
a hundred percent safe.
No one's doing anything to
anybody. Again. Why has the those,
those apartments on Wilshire a few,
it was like century city then
you really have it fairly big.
Like 16 floors. Yeah. Did they fail?
Did they like Americans or did you
feel like they uh, didn't care?
Well, the shows I played two,
we're looking for ex pats.
It was like 15 and 20% of Americans.
So what was the,
it was the rest of it was Chinese. No,
the rest of his English Australia and um,
and they're cool.
I mean there are a little bit conservative
because they don't have any plumbers
that are over there.
Right.
They have like people that have worked
for the embassy or people that are like
work for banks. Right? Right. Little
more conservative and like smarter,
but they're that they're
adventurous people. Right.
People go to work in Shanghai,
we're in Hong Kong instead
of where they from.
It's like you guys are the cool
people that want to do stuff.
That's a good way of looking
at it. I mean, it was,
they were all cool or running
from the law in other countries.
Those are often the good people
as well. Yeah, that's crazy.
So who said this? Well, you don't have
to tell me the person's name, but,
so you had your agents at the salt roads.
Talked to my agent at an airport and he
tells him he goes on those things and he
got me and Schubert went to
a different time. Wow. Yeah.
So it was just these scenes,
they start their own scene and then
they'll bring out a guy to do their four
rooms and then they'll team up with
another guy and another scene. Wow.
And these guys fly from America? No,
there is, and this is the coolest part.
There are brand new comedy seems
starting from scratch in China, in China.
Whoa. Both in Chinese now.
And uh, English speaking.
Wow.
And the people that are already there,
they're working for banks
that are working as teachers.
And then they see a show and
someone goes, Hey, guess what?
Everybody's going to be an open mic next
Thursday because they found some bar
that will allow it. And um, and then
somebody tries cost of these people.
They're like, longest is like
three years. That's amazing. Yeah.
It's all starting from scratch.
There's no rules.
There's no like this is the way it is.
You have to wait till these guys
move on and then you can put,
there's no to learn from either other than
youtube. That's so cool. That's great.
Yeah. That's amazing. From scratch. It was
really exciting when if they take over,
imagine,
imagine if China takes over and becomes
like the number one comedy community in
rural areas,
but co China has this style of comedy
that's like this thousand year old like
Abbott and Costello with cadence changes
so that the new guys that speak both
are like trying to do with like regular
style comedy and people are like, wait,
what is, I don't understand what you're
doing. Oh, so it's a cadence issue. Yeah,
it's like way different than
they're used to. I saw a guy,
there's a video about a guy from Canada
who moved to China and it became a
comedian.
He was a comedian in America,
but he learned Chinese really
learn Chinese speaks. Which one?
Mandarin. I don't know which one,
but people that have done that does,
bishop did it for the last year.
It took a bunch of Chinese
mandarin classes recently.
Chinese. Who's this desk?
Bishop. He's a, uh, he's big in Ireland
but he's from New York originally. Wow.
And he just, I think he did a show
that's a ballsy move. Ballsy move.
Just let the Beijing for a year.
Now he's in his second year Q managing
going from not speaking Chinese to
speaking Chinese for a fucking
living in front of Chinese.
He's such a foreign language.
How I got a towel and like making
fun of the alphabet and like,
and like why the certain symbols,
it looked like certain things. Wow.
Hell and how like how difficult is it
to learn how to talk in that language?
He said you've got to write new
but you can't translate your bits.
You've got to write new bits for it.
References are so off that it just,
it just won't. Why?
And it was a lot of it,
like something is really big and like
Chinese stuff, culture is losing face,
like way bigger than you would think.
Yeah,
but like losing faces.
Like let's say I'm trying to pay for
a meal and you're like, no, I got it.
I'm like, no, no, I got it.
You're like, no, I can pay
it. Like I'd be like, hey man,
you got to let me do this here.
Right.
I put my card out like
you gotta let me do this.
You can't embarrass me in
front of these people. Oh,
it's more than just like
slight embarrassment.
That's another reason why there's
less crime is cause people were like,
what am I going to get caught shoplifting?
Oh that's cool. I'm embarrassed.
I'll be, it's the guard of
the way to not be that person.
So is there statistically less crime?
Like the American Shanghai, you can walk,
they say women can walk three 30 in the
morning drunk and no one is touching him.
Wow. The only violence is acts of
rebellion against this country. Whoa.
It's that country. I mean, yeah.
Where people take out machetes and
fucking hack up a Mazda game. Ooh.
Which they show on the subways by the way.
They show Mahjong Games on the subways.
They show module on Games getting
hacked by these fucking wiggers.
What do you mean South China?
The or rebelling. Okay.
There the 7% minority ethnically, what
are they? What's a weaker, but I dunno,
it's a different ethnic group. How
you spell it? I think w I e. G.
E r but it might be w e. G. E. R.
You can put an ethnic w e I know,
probably come up [inaudible] gun. Yeah,
they look a little different.
They have different food and um,
there's 7% and in some cities like
1% but they don't, I don't know,
they don't like, they want to
break off or something. So they,
they're the ones that got
the big stabbings that were
going on and though these
videos of this module on playing game
going on and this guy just lifts up his
shirt, pulls out an ax, a little hand
axe and just starts accessing this guy.
And then the other guy also
watching, he's like, oh, it's on.
And he just picks up his shirt and starts
fucking accessing these people. Yeah.
Then everyone,
like if it's just mayhem,
somebody like is what
they tried to tackle him.
He comes back to is the axis girl a few
more times and they chased him down.
Weaker. The way it's spelled, it's a
very unusual spelled. It's spelled u.
Y. G. H. U. R.
Wow. I would not have
guessed that. Say that again.
You why g? H. U R wow.
It's also spelled in another instance
you I g h u r y or you die and their
Chinese Muslims.
Yeah, they're always started.
The trouble. The Muslims.
Yeah,
but they showed this on the,
on the subway that's over the kids
there and it's like Jesus, they really,
I mean they blurred right as the hacking
like goes on God the head and stuff.
My God. See that when you're on
the, on the train. Yeah. The show,
everybody now they have complete control
over the media. All the media. So the,
the government has complete control
and it's not hidden. We are here.
Like what does that feel like?
Well,
they kind of don't know that they're
really getting the real story.
So like they say it's the wiggers, but
you know how there's like rumors, like,
I dunno what al Qaeda is and what the
other one is. It's like they say that,
but who knows what that really is. What's
the other group? Al Qaeda and Taliban.
But they're, they're just
like, we really don't know. Um,
but you know, it's different than
here and it's the same as here.
It's like they were going to
put chips in all the computers,
so you couldn't go on sites that tiny,
didn't know that you can't go to Google,
you can go on a VPN and just go through
a different server and get all this
stuff. You know, Google is a
very concerned about China.
Oh yeah. They're concerned.
Also,
other companies are concerned about China
because China will just copy shit. Oh,
absolutely. They have fake apple stores
that are just totally scaffold sorts.
My friend who's turned her sparks, who's
helping run the scene in Shanghai, uh,
so he's bringing mister softee to China.
He got it like a licensing agreement.
The ice cream.
Yeah.
And he's bringing his mister softee trucks
out there and they're starting to do
good, and then someone else will just
paint up van. Exactly like mister softee,
the same exact colors,
serve the same things and just park it
right in front of his mister softee van.
Wow. It just looks like he put to bear
there together at the same time and the
government doesn't do anything.
It's like, what will they do?
You got a good idea now. Now they're, now
they're doing it. That's amazing. Yeah.
Yeah. It's hard that you don't think
in terms of copyright laws. Yeah.
They don't think in terms
of litigation either. Right.
It's just a totally different kind of
culture as far as like our constant suing
of each other back and forth about that.
I don't know. I'm not sure. Maybe. Hmm.
I wonder. It's interesting when
you see that though. I mean,
he's got to be really fascinating for
you to come from our American culture and
be immersed in their culture for three
weeks. I've never done that before.
It was cool.
I've been to Brazil for a few days,
but a lot of Brazilian speak
English and like seven, eight,
nine days though it started to become
like normalized a little bit and there was
like a really observed stuff.
Plus I got a little lonely so I can
make friends easier once you need to.
Did you stay,
how long did you stay in the same place?
Shanghai was the first night I went to
like suburbs of Shanghai for for a few
days and then back to
Shanghai for two days.
They have a proper club called
comfort comedy, which is like, listen,
you proper st proper like an Englishman.
But I mean it's like,
it works as a club.
There's one room,
it looks like the belly room and it's
just like, oh, this is a cool place. Wow.
Other places were bars where they try
to set it up, you know? That's cool man.
It's all these experts who need something.
English speaking,
it's kind of like the Uso tours you'd
ever hear about that where they're like
always really thankful. It's like that,
you know hecklers. They're just so happy.
There's English speaking comedy.
And how many of those people knew you from
online? Zero? No, no, no, no, not zero.
Like a couple people were just there
because they're checking out new comics
that come into town every week. Some
was like, man, I'm a big fan of yours.
Like oh thanks.
Cause yeah,
I check out those videos on the
website that they showed. I was like,
oh that means you saw who was
playing and then you watch TV.
You're not a big fan. That's okay.
But came a big fan of super recently.
It was like, it wasn't like excited.
There was some like a podcast listeners,
you know a few here or there.
That one show second. I had
like seven or eight. Wow.
Couple of Shanghai's just
developing a reputation like this.
These scenes are developing reputation
for bringing funny people around.
So folks just come out to
see who the new guy is.
Like once a month they could bring in an
out of towner. Wow. And the scene starts.
But you can only do the room like twice
with any joke before the like, yeah,
we've all seen it, man. Oh,
drawing from the city of 50,000 tops in
a city of 24 million is 50,000 English
speakers. So do they write a lot there? I
have to, but you know the open mic days,
that's how you did anyway.
You'd write it a lot.
Every week it'd be like
performed from the same guys.
Got to come from their joke.
That's the worst when it's
almost all comics in the room.
Kind of just a couple of audience members,
but the comics of all senior ship
before you can even do an a tagline,
we're not going with you for seven
minutes for your one new bit. Yeah.
You're barely new tagline.
It's just a better version of an
old tagline and you can't do it.
You see when your tagline,
it's not really, it's just
better. It's not that new.
It's just, I've seen your act a
hundred times, just riffing up there.
That's the worst though.
When you're the fucking,
and there's no one in the audience.
It's beaten down and tired and you know,
there's more comics in the
audience and the audiences. Yeah.
So Shanghai's just emerging
and they have a city outside.
They like like a 40 minute bullet train
outside. They're called pseudo. Ooh,
that had the spill. Small town
feel. 10 million people. Oh my God.
A small town. Everything
closed early. That's insane.
10 million people and
everything's closed her own. Yeah.
So is that like Chicago
sized? 10 million. It's Beth.
Bigger than Manhattan in Shanghai.
I mean, so Joe [inaudible] Joe is,
when they say Manhattan, did they, the
[inaudible] on the island. The island.
We're not talking about
the actual full state.
Do they ever actually say that or did
they say New York City Tri Burrows or
something? He said things
that, I don't know.
I don't know what New York City
means. The five boroughs. Yeah.
It's not Triborough. It's five,
right? It's Long Island Queens,
Brooklyn, Staten Island with
Manheim. Breaux Bridge set it. Yeah,
I say it. I don't know what
the fuck one, I don't know.
I never know if they're just talking
about only the island of Manhattan or the
Greater New York.
Like what someone says New York City.
The Bronx is New York City. Van Nuys is
part of La. Yeah. Right, right. Yeah.
To be in like just their sort of,
it's sort of the same kind of thing,
but if you picture just meant hat
this is bigger than that. Whoa.
That's also a lot of people. I remember
the first time I came to Manhattan,
I was driving from Boston.
I think I'd been there once
before for a karate tournament,
but I was like 16 I didn't really remember
it that much and somebody else was
driving know. It was like one of those
experiences. It was really young,
so I was there for a comedy and the first
time I drove I drove up the west side
highway and there was the, there was
the first time I ever saw the skyline,
which is pretty dramatic on the
west side. I went, he's like,
I like the death star. I was like,
this is the craziest thing I've ever,
I was so intimidated. It's
pretty big show. Intimidating,
overwhelming. I was like,
God, believe how big this city is sane.
When they got back up to three weeks,
it was like, oh yeah. I was like,
fuck. I meant all those buildings.
It's a menu. It's just insanity. Did
you feel that when you were in China,
was there, yeah. Which places
out to it? They had it. They had,
they needed a financial district.
And so they had all these rice patties,
like right across the field that 20 years
ago, all rice patties. And they're like,
let's make a financial district. And
there's now this 50 skyscrapers. Whoa.
They just filled them in.
They don't have to like vote.
They don't have two referendums.
They don't have to wait
until it's an election year
show. They're doing anything.
Did you go any of the cities
that were crazy polluted?
Shanghai? How bad? It's bad.
It's bad.
I wasn't there.
And one of those awful days where Dez
bishop at that the Irish guy in Beijing is
not as bad as Shanghai, but it's still
real bad. He says, um, I mean everywhere.
Where's mass tons of people where mass,
not everyone,
40% of the people where mass.
Whoa. They see what the,
everyone has an app on their
phone for pollution. Uh,
and so I was in the unhealthy range
pretty much while I was there.
But if he gets a worse than that,
he goes, you wake up in the morning,
you felt like you smoked all night so
the APP recognizes the air or tells you
what the quality is.
So then they won't like bike to work.
If it's real bad they'll take
across motherfucker. Yeah.
So you have tissue papers,
they give you the pitch everyone
has at all times to wipe it. Yeah.
Cause after SARS everyone
started wearing like,
people look concerned with
spreading it to others too.
So there's no spitting allowed anymore.
Do you know that there's a spread of
murders? It's going on now. Oh yeah.
That signs up for that at every
train station. They're like,
do not bring anything else in. We didn't
want dumping your fucking chickens in.
Yup. Livestock. Yeah. Uh, people
kiss their livestock sometimes.
Really. Dude's kiss their
camels. Try and get you guys,
stop kissing their camera guys, people
are dying. Fuck you're superstitious.
Don't be kissing you Campbell anymore.
And then riding on a train.
Superstitious. And what? I mean,
how long does it take before
like some of the more ridiculous,
we were talking earlier about the ideas
of kosher original origins for it.
We're pretty, pretty smart. Oh, well,
it's pretty smart to not eat pigs if all
these people are dying and getting sick,
but how long does it take for those?
Just totally go away. How long before?
We have no superstitions. Right?
A hundred years. I don't know.
New ones will come in, do you think so?
Throwing the salt over the shoulder,
one of that come, that's
not, not everybody does some
asshole. That's some asshole.
Yeah. That what? When do you think
that that ends in 500 years from now?
Hopefully it'll be done by that. God,
hopefully it's got to happen. Right?
It seems like we're moving that way,
but it's natural to feel like every time
I would do that growing up, I'd be like,
I just believed in southern
superstitions that I thought of. Yeah.
I did touch like we all did it.
It was like a thing.
You ever do one of those things where
if I step on this crack, oh yeah,
whole family might die.
My mom's back broke. Yeah.
Or you try to avoid that old boy
cracks for whatever reason. Yeah.
Like really keep, I was like,
why? What are you doing? Well,
when you confused about the nature of
reality, you think it's very mystical.
Maybe this, I control it. No,
that's not, you control it. Well,
I've always wondered if like the real
origins for superstitions like that and
children are that children have a more
honest awareness of the nature of reality
itself is that it's malleable and then
things you can alter the way things go,
but you want to feel about in stupid
ways like stepping on a crack. Right?
But it might be the way you act or think
or behave and you feel that you sense
it, but you can't sort of communicate it
correctly as the thoughts and process.
It can't put it into context.
So instead you worry about stepping on
cracks and breaking people's backs. You,
you feel this sense that you
have some sort of a weird,
weird ability to affect.
And change your destiny based on
decisions that you make? Yeah.
When the cat goes across
the street in front of you,
do you still get at least like
you think about an egg ladder?
When I say a ladder,
I'll,
I'll usually move around it
the other way instead of like,
what the fuck does this matter? Well,
here's a perfect example of that.
I was kind of superstitious
when I was a kid,
but I've always loved cats and I've
always had cats and nobody's a black cats,
so I never got a fuck about black hats.
So when a black cat,
we'll go across the street. I would never
think, oh my God, I'm fucked. I'd be like,
fuck you. That's the
cat. It's just a cat man.
Give that cat a little bowl of tuna
fish and Pettit. Be Perin just the cat.
But a stray cat is bad luck. He's a
fucking animal. He's having a good time.
Southern White Guy made that thing up.
Probably about the black hat. It's racist.
I think it's just a fear thing.
I think people are afraid because
remember that's witches, right? Black hat.
If you were scared of what we can't see.
Yeah.
Some fucking glowing eyes running
across the road in front of your car.
Cause it's about a car,
right, isn't it? What?
No black cat crosses your path. You got
a bicycle. What do you want to walk in?
Just walk in anytime they're
walking in front of you. That too.
I was thinking of it because the
whole Disney thing with that with a
superstitious guy.
Somebody. What are those?
Umbrella canes and he like moves the cap
backwards so it won't. So even walking,
do you think that's when it
was created or was it click?
It was created then for walking days maybe
a horses would freak out and they see
a cat run across when people are
possibly blend into the shadows.
So it just saw and people fell and
got fucked up. So now I get it out.
Fat could be it or you can't shit
your pants and fall on your rake.
Yeah, you fucking die cause
you don't, you don't know it.
Staph infection in his back
then that's another way to die.
What I saw a guy first day,
whenever someone says, Dude,
you got to give him the floor.
Brown.
He had this leg that had purple
from like just below the knee,
all the way to end. This guy, the
guy who was taking over, I was like,
don't tell him. Look at the, and
I started not looking at like,
how am I not going to look?
I'm just starting.
It was a purple ring about that big and
inside the proper room was like a yellow
ring and then inside that was
like a little bone. Oh my God.
So it was just eating him up. Yeah.
I mean they're homeless are shit.
Whoa. They didn't have to say anything.
They just let their fucking by show it.
They don't tell it. Oh my God. Yeah,
but they don't have much homeless.
That was the only guy I ever saw in
Shanghai that was homeless for these
catalytic cigs excuse. Yeah. Your
leg is wasting away. What do you do?
Like he ain't get amazed.
Probably already did.
Did you have a new found appreciation
for America when you relay ended and now
you ready to say a pledge of allegiance?
Right. I'll tell you what, bad.
There were some things where I felt
a lot more free in China by a beer.
Walked down the street and drink it like
uptown New Orleans. Go to New Orleans.
It could be a brand new Orleans. Not
really very good joint to think outside.
Don't they stop you outside?
Grinding Vegas come.
It's 40 minutes away from fucking
Burbank's is nice, but it's not a safe,
it's not safe spoken joint.
They don't know what weed smells like.
Cops have no reference point.
It's what are you talking about?
Have no reference point. They don't
know what it smells like. Now.
I just solved the whole puzzle.
They don't know what it even smells like.
Countries.
She's confused as fuck.
Did you imagine they'd kept weed from the
whole country? There's so little of it.
Wow. That's amazing. What would happen
if we spread through their country?
Like wow, you got it. Have it. Yeah.
But what would happen if we'd spread
throughout the country at Clark like
wildfire.
If Archie fear became a weed evangelists
for China and got it going but not
there. Don't go there. Do it all through
email. Oh yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah.
You don't want to act. That's still
fucking answer you dude. They'll get,
you don't test them.
They're going to fight tooth and
nail to keep their silly cultures,
keep kissing their camels and shit.
Throw you in a hole for like
ever fucking camels, man.
Kids shouldn't the streets murderers,
the kids shit in the streets.
They're pants are cut down the middle. So
that allows them to, oh my God, no way.
Loose shorts like sports and then,
and then if they're at squatting you
can just see their little dicks and they
train their kids.
I saw one of them and like a market,
she was looking like motioning to him.
You can tell what motions are, you know,
things are universal. And the kid kept
looking back, confusion cause yeah, yeah,
yeah,
do it.
And he like pulled his pants down and
then he's just pissed industries finally
and was just like, do it in the
street. No, you only saw him pass.
It had to smell like shit. They had
their cut all the way to the back.
They're just allowed to shit that stink.
Yeah.
The bathroom smells so bad.
The bathroom smells so bad from pollution.
I think just from the polluted water.
Just polluted water makes it smell wine.
And also they don't, they don't want,
you can't even say it. Look at him.
He just died thinking about it.
They have a lot of toilets.
Was just no toilet. Just a
porcelain hole. The shy one.
Yeah, you have to. Squat is
a squat. It's supposed to.
That's better for your bowels supposedly
pose it.
I was in the Forbidden City.
I was walking around there, the
emperor's palace and I got bad diarrhea.
It was bad. Like sweating
like I gotta fuck, fuck.
And then there's a picture toilet and you,
you go in there and you fucking raw.
It smells.
As soon as you cross the threshold or the,
the smells horrible and you open
up the first toy, the stall door,
and your mind can't even
register it at first.
Like this must be at a construction
now cause there's no toilet here.
So that's the only explanation.
Oh,
and then you go to the next one and
you're like, what? Oh, zip paper rock. No,
there's no paper. What? Yeah. Well
first I just said, I'm not doing this.
I'm not. I walked away.
Oh my God. I was like,
I want to look like two steps out of
the bathroom. And I was like, Oh yeah,
diarrhea. What do you mean I'm not
doing it? Of course I'm doing it.
So you went back in and wash your butt.
You have to do,
so this guy who owned the own, the bar,
the club was in Shanghai, gave me this,
these, this tissue packet,
and he goes, you'll need it.
I thought it was for pollution. And he
goes, you'll need this. And I just had it.
Yeah. And then it was like, oh yeah,
but you got to pull your pants
all the way down. Squat over it,
but also try not to shit into your pants.
Oh,
you can't go over the balls of your feet?
Oh No, there's probably a better way.
What do you do with
explosive diarrhea though?
It seems like you're going to miss lasted
into that hole. You're, you're, you're,
you're like half a foot over the hole.
Is that good for your quads?
It's good for your core.
That definitely
I would feel like that would really
work your core a lot and there's no air
conditioning. It's so hot. That
would work. You're resolved.
That's why the issue is a thing. Maybe
it's not the low sugar diet shit. Shit,
your hit your ankle. So cause I'm going
to have explosive diarrhea. It was like,
I'm just going to hit my picture.
This picture, this I'm down. Okay.
Swatting right now. So like
your, your ass is right.
It's all over the whole filling
the hole essentially feed.
If you're moved far enough away,
what do you do if you have bad knees?
Oh you do after that.
But I sit like that all the time.
That's how I usually just squat, eat
all the time. I do that sometimes.
It's like that. Yeah, sure. Once in a
while back, it's just happening to China.
In one of those toilets,
somebody dropped her brand new phone in
the toilet and so the husband went to go
in there and grab it.
He passed out because of the fumes and
the woman tried to grab the guy out.
She passed out. She passed
out. Two people died.
Three injured falling in stand by me with,
they're all barfing smell
fucking, yeah, we have it.
So good. America, Dick Cheney's,
right. They have those.
They have the shitters on the train
when it's moving around and stuff.
They have those shitters Dick Cheney's.
Right. I open up my tissue packets. What?
What did he say?
Just right.
It sounds like at first I was kind
of jealous, but now I don't want to,
you would never even go there because
even real toilets like in this hotel,
it was fine. In the bars is fine, but
like a lot of places just don't know.
It's going to be one of those,
it's like six or seven tissues in there.
So suddenly you're like got a
budget. Prostitutes, hot chicks.
How was that part of it?
Did you see prostitutes and I
went to the area in Hong Kong.
I didn't got any right, but I went to
the area in Hong Kong. They grab at,
you really want your business now.
A couple of them are hot.
A lot of them were just like older
Chinese ladies that look weathered. Ooh,
Ooh. Here's some interesting Hong
Kong. They don't call it China.
You've got to use your
visa to go between them.
We didn't know it's been given back.
It hasn't been fully giving back yet.
It used to be English. Yeah, for a
hundred years. Well, how did they give up?
How do they let that happen?
How did what?
They said that we'd get it for 150 years
of Puerto Rican Zass for Puerto Rico
back. We'd be like, no way. But that was
always the deal. We want Hawaii back.
They've wanted Hawaii back forever.
No, you're not getting that back.
We want to take less cook. No, I want
ask. It should be its own country,
but at this point, at this point of
China was like, if Britain was like, no,
you don't get it back to,
I was like,
you really want to do this because
if you want to go, we'll go, go.
We'll go in a crazy, we signed
a contract. We'll abide by that,
but it's time to lose faith,
but all the Hong Kong people,
they look at the mainlanders
mainlanders look an insult.
They look at them as like the
garbage people. Really? Yeah.
They'll look the whole thing.
I'll shit and malls and the carry fucking
raw turkeys in their bags and they go
all the murders. That's
all them. Whoa. Oh yeah.
They will view with them is like no
real underlings. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
I was told that, that it was
racist. It gets other Chinese,
but I was like, no way.
How can it be? You know? I was like,
wow, you're right. Deeply, deeply. Whoa.
Like the north. But think of like the
south, but way worse than that. Wow. Yeah.
I'll tell you what, if there's,
if, if someone's shit it them all,
it was a mainlander. Whoa.
Yeah. That's just, it doesn't
mean they're all like that,
but that's, that thinking comes from
there. What seems like their reality?
It's just far more sparse.
There's far,
far fewer resources to many people.
Well what is it that's causing
them to behave in such a,
well they had a lot of revolution in
the last, like not that many years.
Like the old people,
they walk around like you know that walk
where they put your hand behind your
back last bit and just like stroll to
like none of my friends are getting shot
in the face, you know, at a firing squad.
Like they've lived through some bad times.
So they're calm. Yeah. They're like,
we're safe.
They're baiting you with Kamora actually
they tried to get you to go into it.
If you go to that Kamora a lot of guys
have a good defense and they know that
set up that far side on Barb control,
the body will just trip you,
get you to the ground. I don't know
what that is. I don't know what it is.
Hong Kong is pretty built up to. Hmm.
That's fascinating. Were all bankers.
It's the English influence.
So the English influence was
it to the side of the street?
They drive and China drives I guess.
Yeah,
except they don't drive like pedestrians.
I mean it's like if you're crossing
the street like this and you know that
making a right turn. If they see a hole,
they go figure it out for their car.
They're taking it.
Those mopeds is shooting in and out
through traffic through like pedestrians.
How many people get hit? They said
tons all the time. I didn't see any,
but they say tons. Fuck that.
Could you walk across that shit?
Oh all the time. Oh my gosh. Just
keep walking and no, you see me,
you're gonna move or you see my angle.
You want to like stop and throw it off.
Give them timing. You just get, yeah,
just got to trust the same page.
Just trust him not to hit. You got to
trust their timing. Yeah. They're like,
they see where you are. I see where you're
not going to be in like two seconds.
I'll go where you are now.
Don't,
don't stop walking the main
street in characters while
they're driving like that.
Could you imagine they're texting must
be so much more complicated than ours.
They're drawing out a picture. They
do texting characters. Oh my God.
So they texting characters
and they all at night,
especially the cab drivers to save
battery. They'll turn off their lights,
they'll drive it,
drive without that lights it all. But
the darkest cloud is nights. Oh my God,
my in the city you can pretty much see,
hey,
you're just walking across the street and
you have to hope that they can see you
well enough to time you.
I have such bad ideas about they'll turn
off their motor at red lights because I
think that saves. Oh God.
Well it does. We're good.
No it doesn't. No. It's a new
feature and a lot of cars,
what they shut off at stoplights,
really. Portions have it and it doesn't.
Doesn't that take the most
gas to start up again?
It's like in an instance startup again,
the the,
the engine goes into like some sort
of sustained hibernation or some shit,
but it essentially shuts the engine off.
It's an option though.
You can turn it off or on and it's
how they beat emission standards.
Like they want to like push us
over time. It doesn't, yeah.
Maybe for every five minutes were worse,
but over like 10 minutes
where we're better.
If you read those things
where it says like how much,
what's the miles per gallon
that like a car gets?
That's the only driving
like a really sane,
calm person that doesn't take any risks.
You're driving like super slow.
You're observing the speed limit.
You slowly accelerate up to
whatever speed you want to go to.
Look at that. Look at that. That's across
the street. That is fucking insane.
That's just across the street is fucking
crosswalk. Oh my God.
That is fucking, man.
It was just white paint on a road that's
got nothing to do with me is fucking
inspiring. Wow. It's hard
to watch. I get anxiety.
So many of those mopeds too. I remember
one of those fucking drunk late at night.
You that was suck.
Hard to
solid Jude come close at all. Did
anybody come close to hitting? You know,
I mean it wasn't like I didn't
skim one at all, but I'm at,
could feel the breeze go by.
Oh my God, definitely. Damn.
Where's your favorite place?
Who um,
I don't know. Hong Kong was a lot of
fun in Shanghai was a lot of fun to
air bell. Yeah, it's cleaner. Definitely.
We went out junk vote and Hong Kong.
It's like a day before I left.
The day before the last day and a
just jumped off into the, into the,
like the bay and stuff.
It was fucking awesome.
So does essentially just different, but
both. Cool. Both. Cool. Fuck it. Swam.
That's a perfect mix of like beer,
Thai food.
A little bit of acid and just fucking
jelly fish came up at some point.
And you went in the ocean. Yeah.
Wow. Food, beer and acid fish.
Yeah. The jellyfish came out and
they've got a little more dangerous,
but we just kept jumping in and of
jellyfish. Get you, you're fucked.
You just in a lot of pain for two
days, two days. Guardian and I,
my ex had it on her neck and it was
just this huge like really burned how to
like get it out.
You've got to take a credit card loads.
That's the hottest pot loads.
That's what loads do.
They burn you for about six months. They
mark you up. Nobody else can get you.
They don't swim really fast
though. Let's go fast. Go Fast Bro.
You don't know. You don't
know Mike? Just line.
There's a wine Australia that
kills people on a regular basis.
Really kills people.
Have they have these um,
these emergency stations that they have
set up on the beach where they have
these giant jugs of vinegar.
Vinegar? Yeah. He pour it on like,
yeah, it'd be they let
go or something. I Dunno.
I think I should probably Google that.
There's one comic,
Sean got guts done the year before
and they said they had to pee in
a cup and then pour it over it.
But then they said they found out later.
That's not the way that,
that's actually not a thing. Uh, yeah.
Australia has a lot of shows. Really.
How far was trying to from Australia,
it's not that far.
It's not as far as we are from Australia.
I don't think from Sydney.
I think they're closer to
Sydney then we are really south,
but like straight down south,
there's a ton of Asian than Australia.
There's a box jellyfish. It's no bigger
than your finger nail can kill you.
That's hard to spot even when you
haven't bitten your nails lately.
No bigger than your fingernail
and it can kill you.
I gotta pee real bad. Go Pee. I'm
freaking out about a box. Jellyfish
matchstick. Wow. Look at that shit.
Brion pull that shit up. Box Jellyfish.
Just pull up box jellyfish.
No bigger than your fingernail can kill
you in the blink of an eye. By the way,
mother fucker.
Just when I was starting
to relax or is this live?
Is it really Australia,
man? Wow. Look at that.
Look at that shit.
That's how big that is.
Size of a God damn fingernail
and it can kill you in seconds.
That is not cool.
Upon further research.
This itty bitty jelly is so cute
that it might kill you. No, really,
and not from the sheer adorableness of it,
but from it's insanely poisoned.
His sting,
the species box jellyfish was
described as recently as 2007 wow.
So they didn't know about it.
The species of box jellyfish was described
as recently as 2007 after a 44 year
old American tourist,
of course by the name of Robert King
was swimming in Australia waters and
encounter this minute box jellyfish.
He was stung and died soon after.
That's where the name of
common king slayer comes from.
After Robert King, that's
the guy's name. Wow.
They called this fucking jellyfish I
king slayer because it killed this guy
named Robert King.
They didn't know about this jellyfish
until 2007 so this guy's got stung.
He died from a tiny jelly fish.
They didn't even know of this.
Spot it size of your fingernail. Look
at it, look at the images of it. Brian,
pull up some of the images. There's some
of them where they have one in a test,
a little tiny test tube and it's all
over Australia. Especially Sydney.
He's just done. I don't know where it
is, man. I'm just making shit up. Oh,
but it's in Australia somewhere.
Especially sitting there cause you know
I'm looking at the size of that.
You see how tiny it is? Wow.
That thing can kill you.
And it didn't kill a guy until 2007 and
so they decided to call it the common
king slayer.
That's what it's called now.
That's pretty wild because it killed
a guy named Robert King. It's,
he didn't kill anybody till then.
Nope.
We didn't even know about
contact with humans.
They never knew about it.
Oh I like this. This is,
this is from a box jellyfish
mother fucker things.
Oh my God, is it this one
girl? It wrapped around.
It didn't just thinking it wasn't
wrapped around and held on.
And then all the things,
all the alarms are going into,
well this is a type of box jellyfish
they've known about box jelly fishes for a
while,
but this type of box jellyfish,
the common king slayer was discovered as
recently first described as recently as
2007 wow. So they didn't know about
it until this guy got fucked up by it.
Oh,
Steve Steven went to this beach where
there's just tons of jellyfish and he'd
just started putting them on his hat head.
Yeah, it's a great video. Check it out.
Yep. How's he know which ones
they are? The fucking guy.
That wild man guide. They would tell him
all the time. Yeah. What was his name?
The old man Manny.
Yeah, maybe it was cool.
Steve O actually put like a
poisonous jellyfish on him.
He got stung for me. Yeah,
absolutely not like that guy.
I got stung by the box jellyfish box.
Jellyfish chances in that
show. Yeah. That is so
weird, man. It's so weird that these
things exist that can kill you so easily.
Oh,
that's so weird.
It's just weird that these things exist
that have venom in them, you know?
Yeah. There's no antivenom for box
jellyfish. Wow. For these box jellyfish,
a little tiny ones. There's none.
Only symptoms can be treated,
which can last from
hours to, uh, two weeks,
weeks of symptoms if
you live motherfucker.
Yeah. There's going to be
researching jellyfish in the
next month. This is crazy.
This is really funny.
Part of this is what it does to you.
This is really interesting.
The severe symptoms don't rear their ugly
heads until about five to 120 minutes,
30 minutes. On average.
The, uh, some syndrome,
it's characterized by severe pains
at various parts of the body,
typically excruciating muscle
cramps in the arms and legs,
severe pain in the back and kidneys,
a burning sensation of the skin and face
headaches, nausea, restlessness, sweating,
vomiting, increase in heart rate
and blood pressure. And last,
but certainly not least,
a psychological phenomenon which can
z consists of the feeling of impending
doom. Well, it sounds like
with all that other shit,
of course you would think that it does.
You're dying.
How's that even like an additional,
is it a separate thing? It's no,
it's like you're dying, man. You can jack.
Think about all that shit. Severe pain,
excruciating muscle cramps, severe pain
and back and kidneys, burning sensation,
skin and face, headaches, nausea.
You know you're dying. Yeah.
Vomiting your fucking time.
But who wouldn't?
You'd have to be the cockiest
motherfucker ever to be like, yeah
bro, he's fucking box. Jellyfish ain't
killing me, dude. This is like a,
it's like a cold. I have cold
grandfather's swimming every day.
He didn't get a lot of jellyfish.
This is incredible.
It's scary. It's scary as fuck that nature
creates these little things like that.
They can just back you just probably
some goldfish to eat it. Fine. Knock,
knock on the sheets off of it. Right.
And it's probably some shitty bird.
We did fish eating, like eating
at one of them and it's trying to,
it's like trying to get out of there. So
I'd have to dive the, get a jelly fish.
So fish to eat. Jellyfish. Yeah. I
mean it has to be what they created.
I mean they have to create, it should
avoid preparation. That's a good question.
Souls, they served jellyfish. They served
you a little bit. So the restaurants.
Yeah, I didn't get any. I
was getting other stuff.
Can we play the WII Istio video or
would that get us Yang from youtube?
Probably get Yang from youtube.
Steevo went and do this to us.
Who owns this Tivo footage though?
He'll be happy if he should. Yeah. Okay,
let's show it then.
I want to see him get fucked up.
I'm trying to get you ever see the video
of Steevo when he's up in a tree and
lions come up to him that swiping
and barely missing is but no,
they swabbed his hat.
They took his hat.
He had like one of those Mexican farm
worker hats, you know, Straw hats.
Those do like to wear and
he's up in this tree and this,
this lion runs up to him in the tray,
just runs up the tree.
He's checking them out.
Female Lion and she like bites his hat.
She doesn't bite him.
She bites this hat and he's
like stuck up there on the tray.
It is the most terrifying thing anybody
that I've ever met has ever done.
God was that the guy died, was his buddy
from that show? Wild boy. He was Steve.
I was alive. No, the other guy,
that's what killed him. No,
he fucking car car. The guy had
died in a car crash was one of the,
the guts from the other show. From Jack
wasn't. Yeah, it wasn't from wild boys.
He died speeding drunk in a Porsche.
Yeah.
That's what they were not from
all that other crazy shit.
Not from all the other crazy stuff,
but the chances,
I mean they just tell us guys just every
day would risk their lives. I mean,
that was Johnny Knoxville was the Goddamn
movie star and he's putting a Bandanna
over his eyes and letting the bowl
thrown through the air. That is the nuts.
Nutty as fuck. Can you talk about
the best comedies? You're like, oh,
what are the dirty good comments? You
know, maybe you mentioned three or four.
All three of those jackasses
were fucking awesome. Awesome.
Just laughs every 10 seconds. Did you
see the new one with the old man? No.
What is it called? GRANDPA. GRANDPA. God
Damn, that's funny. The unedited version.
Yeah.
If you haven't seen it yet,
it's like the 2.0 or whatever version
you check it out. It's even more worse.
I couldn't even imagine. It could be
better done. Movie was really funny,
like there's some really,
really,
really funny scenes like Grandpa's stuff
they did and Jack House was awesome.
He's awesome.
Johnny Knoxville is so good.
He was riding that rocket and the thing
went off and blew a hole through the
metal rocket like right by his
head is like, Whoa, I was so close.
I would have been gone. Yeah. Could
you imagine if that's how he died?
Rocket to the fucking head on one
of those Shiny Knoxville filming?
It's done and everyone would be
like, oh, oh yeah, of course.
Why doesn't that happen before? What is
it about dudes who want that feeling,
that rush of getting right up to the edge
because those guys get right up to the
edge. But Steve Steevo
backed off a lot. Right?
Got Off the drugs.
Yeah. He's a boy. He's completely
sober, which is awesome.
[inaudible] now I talked to him
like six months ago, you know, like,
so I'm in San Diego and he
had a sex addiction that he
was trying to get off of.
And then uh, then we're
throwing them under the bus. No,
cause I think it talks
about it and then maybe,
but then like this last time I saw him,
like just a month ago,
I went down and again to see him and uh,
he uh,
he had a guy that came with him to make
sure he did [inaudible] sex addictions.
That's hilarious. I was a joke. I'm
going to tell you something right now.
A guy like,
he was supposed to have a sex addiction
block for the best because if you,
the amount of, that's his job. I'm a cock
block. Go. My name is Johnny, Johnny.
Johnny. When Tom's a cock blocker,
you got a sex addiction. Don't worry,
I'll get it.
I'll go with three pronged effort.
Are going to mention your
daughter in front of them.
I'm going to talk about your treatment
and leave it blank and then treatments a
big one and then I'm going to fuck her.
Well a guy like that, like he probably,
I mean he's a famous dude, Steve Olds,
famous dude.
So I bet some really hot chicks
launched themselves in his direction.
He's pretty God damn famous. Yeah.
And he's famous for being a wild man.
So really crazy bitch is probably
tracked it to him like a magnet to metal
shavings. Let's start moving across
the desk at him. It's probably normal.
Right?
So for a guy like that,
the amount of love and sex he must be
getting or thrown his direction offered.
Damn. It must be pretty stunning. Let's
be high. And he's probably, you know,
it looks in the mirror,
he knows what he looks like.
I may as well cash enough to take
myself up on this opportunity. You know,
it's wood. What you, no one
else gets that shot. No one.
Only one guy gets to be steevo. Yeah.
You know, I said that to you once.
I remember that because it, it
struck with me too, as I said it,
we were talking about comedy and
we're talking about creating like when
someone's a fan of yours. The craziest
thing is like if someone's an artist,
your fear fan, you're the only
one that give them Ari Shaffir,
they'd be coming to Arusha for your fan.
You're the only one who's doing an
arch for your comedy. Yeah, that's it.
You're responsible. You're
responsible for that shit. Yeah.
So I'm sure he feels the
same way. Yup. Probably. Wow.
Yeah. It was like Steve
Over, I'll let me cash in.
Cash is girls at ultimate
fan of Steve Bows.
Why would he not nonsense.
Do you mean he has sex a lot and it's
awesome because that's what you're saying.
A lot of times I feel all
alone of Christian person
going and you shouldn't do
that too much, but of course
there are sex additions of course,
but there's everything addictions,
right?
I mean there's addictions to
fucking washing your hands.
It's like you can't carry on with his
day so they can't get anything done.
Then it's like,
I guess that's an addiction,
but isn't it parallel to
what we were talking about
earlier about the cigarettes?
That becomes like force of habit,
right? It becomes part of your life.
It comes like a, uh, a well
worn trail in your mind.
I like sex a lot,
but then if I've got work to do,
if there's something I have to do,
I'm like I can't,
I gotta like I gotta take care of
this. So you're not sick, right?
You don't have the,
the sickness if you,
some people like to call it no. Will.
Some people like to call it no discipline,
not me. I prefer illness. Disease.
I want to take it completely
out of your control.
Did we crash the also we offer
Ustream right now? No, no, no, no, no.
I mean the youtube crashed, crashed,
but we're still on Ustream stream.
So we're still at a youtube video
of this show. You by the way,
that you could probably play,
I guess the sex addiction thing,
when it becomes a problem,
it's when he starts spending money and
we start being sloppy and having sex with
no condoms.
With people in the streets when you're
doing really liked doing the want to do
or you really like doing that and
it's way better than not doing that.
I'm not this.
One of the things that I don't buy.
I think it's when you look at
yourself later and go, fuck,
I don't want to do that.
Why can't I stop doing that?
And that's everything that's beating off.
That's using Q tips,
that's fucking biting your fingernails.
People get weird. People are weird.
We're weird. I saw this guy, somebody was
talking about losing a bunch of weight,
some comic at a barbecue and this
other fatter comic and he was like,
they were talking about eating natural
chips and stuff instead of like processed
stuff. And the federal
guys was like, man, Louis,
you gotta show me how to lose weight
as he's like eating the chips. He goes,
well I just told you, but
still eat those things. Yo,
you got to rewire my brain
and make it awesome. Yeah,
I got to do it all the way for him
in his lazy ass bitch ass brain.
That's a problem, man. If people don't get
their brains rewired in some way, shape,
or form. If you're a lazy fuck, it's very
difficult to wake up one day and go, oh,
I'm not going to be a lazy fuck.
Yeah. So if you don't get, yeah,
if you don't get early going, I have
lazy tendencies. Yeah, we all do.
And it's one of the reasons why I'm not
lazy at all cause I'm terrible should
against it. I don't like it. I liked
that part of me. I don't have cable.
I know I could watch TV all day. I
couldn't move. I'm never getting rid of.
Mine can really like coming on
right to internet. I like if I work,
especially if I could do a show,
show goes well, everything's great.
I listened to set on the way home.
I know the new bits I'm working on.
I don't have a responsibility as far as
writing and I don't like to write too
late at night when I'm, and then you
watch cable and you get home. Yeah,
I write late at night,
but only if I am home.
I don't go out and then come back and
write cause I feel like I'm tired.
So I like to relax in front of the TV.
All download TV.
I just won't have cable so
I can have it all the time.
I'll still watch the shows. I watch, get
everything now on Apple TV, Hulu, Netflix.
But then when it's done, you
don't automatically like,
oh this next show started.
I guess I'm watching
this now to get cosmos.
Can you get like all the regular shows?
The good rule of thumb is you can
get anything that's ever been made.
So if it's in that group,
you could pretty much get it.
So you don't need a TV anymore
that's hooked up to cable.
You just need good Internet connection.
Any new server,
only bad thing that you were
running into is live. Love.
He v which now find the problem.
Go to a bar and see that that's
the way to be seen. For sure.
Sports that EU is fucking garbage.
It's skips constantly and
cuts out today and Pasa Dena,
a young man came home to find
another man sleeping in his bed.
That fucking type of talk, that news type
guy, how does that, they have to die,
not die like as in physically
but die off that business,
that fucking news business
now with like chrome cast
though and an apple TV,
you can just stream from your phone
like you know like nbc.com so you could
watch the local news stream to your apple
TV anyway, so it doesn't, the problem
is there any bigger dinosaur in our
culture? Then the local news show,
is there any bigger dinosaurs on
the five o'clock news sitcoms,
President Obama met with Egypt.
You're not going to say shit.
You're not going to say the same
shit. We all know. You know,
we don't all know you're in.
You're in with the government.
You're not going to say shit. On top
of that, you've got three minutes,
you got three minutes, you get a
bounce around to five different things.
You know what somebody
pointed out was so scary,
but the company to help Bush was like,
I can't let you show the, uh, the,
the caskets coming back. Yeah,
I met Obama was like, okay guys,
we're going to stop that. You're,
you're allowed to show them.
And now they just don't
show them out of just fear.
So the news just doesn't show them.
They just don't on their own.
So whatever was told to them,
it was like,
what do you think about all the
shit that's going on in Iraq?
Do you know what's happening in Iraq?
Jihadists are taking over Iraq as
soon as we left. How crazy is that?
It was a vacuum that we made.
It's not our fights, man.
I know it's not our fights, but
what a disaster. A disaster.
We did nothing to help them.
What could you do to stay there forever?
We're running shit now. And that's
not what you want to be. That's it.
Then you're an occupying force. That's
the move. Nobody wants to know. No.
It's obviously the move.
You can't let the geodes tangle.
You want to jihad is state run by geodes.
What about the children?
I'll tell you one thing,
please do.
So they had this thing that
we're going to do in China.
They're going to put chips in every one
of the computers so that you couldn't go
on Vpn so you couldn't go on
the stuff they didn't allow. Um,
and the people got really mad about it.
They were like, that's fucking ridiculous.
And they got like start,
they wrote down,
they didn't apprise but they were all
upset and the government was like, oh no,
I won't do it.
Well they were worried whereas here,
that's just something we were going to
do and not tell anyone until Snowden told
us. But that's just something we were,
they at least ran it by their people.
We were just going to do it in secrecy.
Forced the companies to do exactly that.
Yeah. Interesting. When that
happens. Yeah. Did you see that?
So we can talk about like ultimate
freedoms. It's like, Eh, I don't know.
I don't know which one's worse.
Are you,
what do you get really freaked out?
I just found this out by PDC or you know,
you remember PD,
if you go into your security on your,
your privacy on your phone and then
you go down to a location services,
you click on location services,
then you go all the way down to a
system services and then you go down to
frequent locations.
Then we'll just say like,
it'll show your history and uh, let's
just say, uh, we'll click on Los Angeles,
nine locations recorded and it's just
showing locations that I've been like the
last nine days.
The exact address I've been in.
Where you're driving around the hung
out at like I went to New York four
locations. Is it places where
you stopped and made a call? No,
where I stopped and it just shows
that I wasn't driving anymore.
That got hung out.
Shows exact dots on a map of New York.
It's like the map of the exact
addresses of places I've been.
And how do people not know about this?
I've just finding out about it on
the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Can you shut that off? Can you
shut it off? You can turn it off.
And now what apple is saying that that,
that you use it for is,
is that it will automatically
become smart. Your phones,
your maps are smart,
smart knows you're running from the law.
Yeah. Right. And that's why like
if you, if you use like, uh,
like different things like Google
home where it says like, Oh, you know,
your trip to Pasadena Ice House right
now it's 20 minutes. And I'm like,
why are you telling me this? Like have
you seen that? Yeah, I got it. It's done.
Shit like that.
It's the same thing.
It's just to improve maps
and things like that.
So that's why you can
tell you can turn it off.
The government gets a hold of it and
finds out the warehouse where you're
storing the drugs. Right, right. Is that
crazy, Ari or storing the draw? Yeah,
exactly. Well, if you're storing
you going to the drug house,
don't bring your phone. Don't bring
her exactly at a burner phone. Well,
he's stopped here four times.
Let's go check that out.
Get one of them flip phones from tank.
Yeah, that's a good point. Right?
Here's all those jellyfish check.
I'm going to look at there on the
beach right here. This is a Steevo,
but where am I going?
Hi. Went around here. That's
what we'll never do that.
He's got to put a sub
and here's my business
and business is good.
Can you just tell me so many?
Oh,
so he's,
he's gonna throw the Jellyfish Times head.
Do you think that just feels right?
Weird hurts.
I don't know because it hurting.
I think it probably just feels, it looks
like it just feels weird. Oh my God.
Look at the size of that thing.
Oh, he hit him with a ton of gold. Oh
Damn. Oh, he's in pain, right? He's,
he's so crazy.
He's sitting on his back.
Amazing Agony. Screaming
and running. Oh my God.
And anthem background.
Oh my God. He's just running around
in agony. What does it say afterwards?
Nothing sucks out of my chair.
So she scribed here and if you haven't
seen my incredible pop Errante prego
killed with Paris. Tell
that Jesus Christ loved you.
And then I hated y'all in one
video. Youtube. Steven. Wow.
What a crazy guy. Jelly fish.
Well, he's a better man than I.
Yeah, it's not happening. He's
just always wanting to go for it.
The grossness and the snort. It was Sabi.
Yeah. Fuck all that, man. Scott crazy.
I just can't imagine. I can't imagine
someone would actually want to do that.
That seems like a fucking terrible idea,
but we watched it so he wins. Right?
He wins. That's what his objective is
achieved. Yeah, exactly. It was cool.
It's worth watching,
by the way.
My storytellers show is recording
September 9th oh, ain't shit.
I started working on that
story. Yeah. Yeah. Nice.
I got that bitch tightened up
now. Cool. So far it's you Diaz,
big j crushers in Nice TJ millers in
there trying to get Joan Rivers to do it.
Oh, snap. Yeah, that'd be cool.
That'd be very cool. Yeah.
That's interesting. Yeah. The corner
after a few cool people too. Yeah,
so I'm doing your show man. That, that,
that was really fun. Yeah. You liked it.
Loved it. I loved the set
up that it was in cheetahs,
which is like a dingy strip club because
going into it, that's what we did.
It in Montreal the first time we're
doing it again this year actually much at
all, but it's up stairs in
this, the trainee Strip club,
so you walk up the stairs,
you just feel like darker and then no
matter what's said, it's like, go for it.
I'm already been anesthetized
against this trainee ship.
You're not allowed to say
training anymore, by the
way. I transgender what? Yup.
Yup. It's like saying fag. Oh really? Yep.
But you could still call cabbies cabbies.
They're going to get upset now.
They're okay for now, so we've got to
use it up while we can in the future.
It'll be one of those things where
it's like, you know, like Tom Sorey,
they don't say like it was,
it was a Jew in the word nigger.
They took it out of Tom Sawyer. They
took it out of huckleberry out. That's,
I was just thinking about that. That's
the problem with people going well that,
well that certainly certain
lines that you shouldn't,
people shouldn't listen
to it. I'm like, no,
you just shouldn't listen
to it and just turn it off.
Otherwise you're like the
exact same people that took
out that edited huck Finn.
Yeah. It said, no, we can't
have that book in there.
You can edit that out so you
can't write what you write,
but I'm allowed to go to the school board
and tried to get him to take it out of
the libraries.
That's what you're doing when you
contacted the network and saying,
we want this band.
Yeah.
You have to reflect a time in an
accurate way because it's not about you.
You're pretending to people
haven't evolved socially
since the 1920s or whatever
the fuck they made. 18
something did he made. Yeah.
That's part of being a human beings.
Understanding that there's
a constant series of
changes and things people grow.
Cultures evolve.
We're seeing in in front of our own
fucking eyes because the internet,
we're seeing blowback.
We're seeing people get super sensitive
about shit they shouldn't get so
sensitive about and they just,
other folks embrace it just because they
want to be in and out of fight and pick
a side and you know and
look for like really suit,
like the fat acceptance movement. Do
you know that, oh, I'll fight that. No,
you're going to die.
I'm not going to accept that you're going
to die early and it's disgusting and
you smell, Dude. You're so Adeline.
One of those will stop stopped being like
that. What about what bad except
dance? No, I do not accept it now.
Now you're so angry.
Not even in a my day think it's
gross and you're going to die.
It's clearly unhealthy.
Dumped, stopping, gross,
but isn't that another thing just like
a sex addiction or a gambling addiction?
It's a food addiction.
No,
I don't care what anybody says
about fridges in the eyes of others.
It does a little bit sometimes on a plane,
but when anybody says about the causes,
the causes of it,
for sure. Some people have a
faster metabolism for sure.
Some shirt and get away with
eating anything. We all know dudes.
I could just eat anything and they never
get fat. I'm closer to one of those.
Yeah, but we also know that if they stay,
but your stomach, what are they doing?
They're making your stomach smaller. That
means you take in less food. It's it.
So it's a willpower thing. So you're just
taking less. You need less to fill up.
This mother fucker did it. He
lost 80 pounds, Brian. Yeah,
Brian lost 80 pounds once I'm back
most of it. But he lost 80 pounds.
Same thing with Joey is Joey
Dee has lost 80 pounds. Yeah,
he gained back 67
somewhere. I Dunno. I Dunno.
But, but the idea is that if you
could just get it off, keep it off.
Some guys have got it,
got it off and keep it.
I mean I guess there is such a
thing as a, as, as an addition,
but I think it's way more
people just going like, well
I'm in that group. Like, no,
you ain't heard you just stopped going
to the diner at three 45 it's also,
they get addicted to having certain
types of foods in their body,
like sugars that, you know, like there's
a lot of people you get used to it.
If I, if I have enough days
in a row of lots of candy,
which is every day and then if I go a
day without it by 6:00 PM I start getting
like low blood sugar. Yeah, he got
to stop beating cancer. I know. Yeah.
I'm trying to get off.
I was doing a lot less of that in China.
You don't take caffeine in? No.
No Caffeine. It's hilarious. Yeah.
Translate and sugar.
I can see the negative effect on me,
but caffeine has benefits,
antioxidant effects,
cognitive benefits does they
show up? That's good. Yeah.
That's probably better because you
get some caffeine from the tee,
but he is like drinking like a
very mild vegetable soup. Really?
Yeah,
the lights lights too though.
There's like some certain
type of vegetable nutrients
that you can get, you know,
not a lot of it very watered down,
but it's actually not bad for you.
Like a lot of teas are
actually quite good for you.
They say even the caffeine sees is
really the caffeine stays in the leaf,
so it's not really coming
off it into your stuff.
But I never had got jacked from tea. I
never had drank tea and I was like, whoa.
Once I started losing my voice,
I just did a little research like,
what makes you lose your voice?
And one of them was,
one of them was caffeine and I was
like, I'm done. I've never heard that.
Never heard Caffeine dehydrates
you in some way. It's caffeine.
They definitely said alcohol. They said
smoking, but I'm like, look, I'll make,
I'll make do where I can fully
used to drink pots of coffee.
Really hot pots.
You said he pretty much ran that show.
Start to stop to top to bottom.
Dave Foley didn't pretty much won the
show.
Paul Simms definitely ran the show.
He was the guy who
produced it and created it.
But Dave Foley was what I would
call like a secret producer,
an uncredited producer. He
just took control of it. Well,
he was just really good at creating
sketches because of kids in the hall.
So good. Really good. I saw
them live somewhere. Oh yeah,
you're telling me he was really good at
creating moments and so Dave would see
like a scene.
And the reason why he was
able to do that was that Paul,
like he saw that that
was a benefit they had.
They had super healthy egos about
that stuff. Like they would let us,
we could ad Lib all the time.
Especially for the first four years.
We did a lot of ad libbing and
Dave Foley was a big part of that,
like restructuring entire scenes the
first four years at the meeting before,
before Phil died. Yeah. Yeah.
But um, uh, Dave, you know,
he just had a great sense of it and
it was just a really open sort of an
environment where they allowed
like Andy Dick, you know,
they allowed him to be him.
Like they allowed him to open up
and expand and expand the character.
Like he would have these,
these moments and he would add a bunch
of things to the moment to make the more
ridiculous and preposterous and
we would add things to each other.
Like I would write like
occasionally write for Vicky Lewis.
Like I could see how she would
make something really funny.
And so like we would like,
we would do it for each other.
Like she might suggest
something to me and like she,
she would see like your character
from an outside point of view.
I say something like that. Yeah.
That would work well. That was a,
it was a weird environment and robbery,
Huh? Yeah, it was a great camaraderie.
There was a, it was a great cab. That
was a really good show man and Sims,
great show. There was like a
straight actors too, like uh,
like Steve Rowe who's
whole fucking hilarious.
But he essentially would just take the
lines and go into his character and then,
you know, like creative office space
and like, you forget about him.
He's doing great. He's great. He's just
fucking great guy. Take a serious tool.
He gave $1 million, some charity. You're
like, how good are they doing his career?
He him $1 million to some charity.
Did it really? Wow. So it runs the,
she said not as easy. You might've
made that up. Might have been $20
I could see him doing that though.
He's such a nice guy.
He really had a lot of money
laying around. I might do
it suddenly cared about.
He's a,
he's a very interesting real artists.
Like that's how I described Steven route.
Like when it comes to like being an actor,
he's a real artist.
He was some of the money too at some of
them are into it like that where it's
like he was legit.
You're add something.
Plus you couldn't say anything bad about
the guy as a person. Very nice person.
Always a very nice person. But the
most impressive actress was a actor.
It was more attorney. Well I didn't
even know she was acting sometimes.
Like we'd be doing a scene together.
Like sometimes we'd fuck
off in the middle of scenes.
People joke around and she would get
back into the scene and she was, it was,
she was so good. Like you couldn't tell
that she was acting sometimes. Does that,
if that makes any sense. Yeah.
Like her ability to act. You know,
I didn't really never
even took acting classes.
I took a couple lessons and private
lessons that Disney made me take with this
really crazy lady who was trying to
get me to her to be my mom in a sitcom.
They created a sitcoms. Oh she
was so crazy. And I did it for,
because they made me do it.
I took these acting classes.
Try to get you to put her in it. Yeah.
It was humiliating to, it's like she was,
it was uncomfortable.
It was such an uncomfortable scenario.
Like they hired her to do it,
but she was like really a weird with,
well she said weird shit to me too.
She's like,
I'm worried you're going to go over
there and you're going to fail.
Oh she said that's I put putting my head.
Yeah.
But I'm not good at that
shit and you know, because I,
I people played head games with me
all throughout my childhood in fights.
Like that would be at the way people would
say weird head games shit to you when
you were weighing in. Like what's going
to be like when I knock you out? Oh,
that's not going to happen, so don't worry
about it. Have a nice night. You know,
I'll see in a few minutes. Okay, and
I'm gonna kick you in your fucking face.
I didn't say shit like that to each other.
So like when you knew that you were going
to have a fucking kickboxing match and
then you're talking shit to
somebody at the weigh ins,
the difference between that and some lady
who was an acting coach trying to tell
me that she thinks I'm
going to go over there.
I'm worried you're going to go over
there and you're going to fail. I'm like,
well, you don't need to worry about
that and don't talk to me like this.
This is so gross. Passive
aggressive. Like, why?
Why are you worried that I'm going to
fail because I got something that you
never got the shut up.
This is a stupid way of talking to people.
You don't ever say, I'm worried you're
going to go over there and fail.
What does that,
what does the God,
I'm not the best actor in the world have
never been, but I know how to do it.
It's not that hard when
you're acting sick Tom Style,
if you pretend that it's really broad.
Exactly. So when I'm doing that I'm like,
I know what I'm doing here.
Like
Jesus' command to the line.
Again, it's not that hard,
but it was also good.
Writing is the most important thing.
Cause News radio had its harbor.
There's really your writing.
It had perfect writing at many times.
It was like the best written shows for
by far the best written thing that I was
ever a part of,
but I wasn't a bad show before that.
There's Fox show was terrible.
Yeah,
the baseball show was
diggity diggity dog shit.
It was so bad and so that's way harder
to do when you do a show like news radio,
it's easy to be good because the writing
so you can get into it more ideas. Good.
They let you, they let you say, I'm
going to change his lines a little bit.
So this sounds about some more like
to say if you let someone be involved,
I think this is where Paul Simms with
a genius and not just in the fact that
he's a really good writer,
but he also recognized that if you let
someone be a part of the creative process,
there are even more invested in it. They
enjoy it even. Oh yeah, that's right.
I mean,
I think that was it.
It was also that they were always
just no ego looking for the best line.
And Foley would always come up with the
best line. He was so good at that. It's,
you know, he's one of those
guys, man, you know, he's,
he's been on the podcast
before talking about his, uh,
the problems that he's had in divorce
and alimony and child support and stuff
like that. That. He's one of
those guys that like when I,
when I think about the fact that he might
have been like derailed and a lot of
ways because of this horrible relationship
that he is still tied up to and
financially with and still a part of some
crazy divorce proceedings going on and
on and on because he owes back alimony
or child support or whatever that can
worse relationship on that
show. The second worst. Yeah.
He had the second worst out, the worst.
That was the other thing you get used to.
You get used to seeing all these people
interact with other people of their ilk
and that's where I developed my no head
shots policy. Very important. Yeah.
Being around
actors interacting with other actors
and they're both crazy and they're both
trying to work it out and you know,
just, it was just too much chaos,
too much chaos there with famous people
trying to hang out with other wanting to
be famous people or other famous people.
It's very weird.
There's also the weird dynamic,
if only one of you as
successful and you're both in
the same business, not good.
Not Good.
I've had friends that were successful,
but they dated unsuccessful actresses
and the unsuccessful actresses was always
try to get them to mention
them to a casting director.
Did you say, did you say,
did you talk about me?
Because that movie,
he's casting that movie and I am
fucking perfect for that part.
He doesn't know that I'm
perfect for that part.
But you have to tell him I've seen that
shit isn't no, because you're not. Yeah.
Or the other way.
It's even crazier when it's a check and
the checks making mad money and on TV in
front of the camera.
Do something with your life that Weasley
do this behind her sweaty holding our
hands. And what do you do, Tom? You
know, a producer of sorts? Well,
I'm working on the script right now.
It's kind of a romantic comedy
involving my wife and another man.
That's all I got. Yeah. Yeah.
W th the dominant female,
the dominant female
star with the Beta male,
the Beta male behind her hanging in there,
clinging people tell you it's normal.
It's totally normal. It's totally
normal, bitch. I ain't normal.
Not Normal.
It gets
so hard. People like the Yin and the
Yang of relationships. Very difficult.
I've seen so many cool relationships
that at some point became deaf.
No, they just, the girl turns and
they go, what are you doing? I mean,
you've got to get a better job. You've
got to do. It was like, well, why?
Because you're going have better
job. Yeah. Wow. Wow. I just,
but it gets in the way that's, they're
like, that's their breeding. Well,
it's also you hanging around with comics.
Yeah, and it's about, it's like, yeah,
I'm going to struggle for a while.
Well, just a lot of comics that there,
they get married and the girl wants
to have a baby and then she worries.
How are you going to be able
to feed the baby? I don't know.
Why did you get involved
with the fucking broke comic?
What'd you think he was going to
do? Suddenly be a banker. Okay.
Yeah. To help them. You Fall in love with
love with and I fell in love with
you. Okay. I'm fucking tired.
I wish it didn't happen, but it did.
It's a spell. It's a magic spell.
Well, well, I fell in love with you.
It was your love for abortion. Oh No,
things are tight. Goodness. How dare you.
That's a perfect thing to say right there.
How dare the, yeah. Have you talked to,
if you talk to someone that you're dating
them and you know this is never going
anywhere and they're like thoroughly
to abortion, you're like, yeah,
it does get an ugly.
That's good in the worst way because
unfortunately there are, you know,
Patrice had a fucking
great joke about that.
Patrice had a great joke about
people getting mad that, you know,
you don't want to have the same kind of
relationship they have and it's like,
yeah, he goes, it's like if you are
applying for a position and you know,
you want to be the president
of, of uh, General Motors, well,
the president of General Motors that,
that job not available,
but the job is available that I come
over your house to clock in the morning,
drink your last snap when you
suck my Dick, that jobs available,
like that position's available.
That's the only position that's available.
They're going to leave and tell
me whether you want this position,
like don't like that's
the kind of relationship,
that's the kind of relationship we have.
You know,
you can't get mad at me that I don't want
to make it something different. Yeah.
This is what I have open for you.
I call this girl on some city that
I'd hooked up with here or there.
I met her at Brayer, one of your shows.
Actually I'm on my own brand. Yeah,
real cool.
And uh,
we've done it on and on for a few years
and then I found her in some cities.
She was living there now and she was like,
actually I got a boyfriend now.
I was like, we should, you want to
hang out when, because you know,
I'll hang out with sometimes. And she
goes, you don't have to. I mean, honestly,
our relationship has only ever like
that one thing. And I was like, yeah,
you're right. It was,
wow. That's a lot to you.
So you offered to just hang
out and be like a nice guy. No.
First off to hang out and then also sex,
but I don't spell that out. I was also,
I see, so you felt like if you got close
to her and you're hanging out together,
sex with probably happening.
I'm sure it would,
but I was also like lonely in
that city. I was like, Hey,
there's some new movie out this week.
You want to go see it? And then, yeah,
you don't have to say, obviously we're
going to fucking play their music playing,
Bro. What's the music sound like?
Like a Cat Stevens Song. Oh, nice.
Cat's in the cradle and dad.
That was the hold music they played
for the homer lost his child.
I couldn't find Bart,
so I was like missing persons and
they start playing that for the, Oh,
God is crying. Wow. That's rough.
Yeah, it's w you know, I read
something, it was like advice to men.
It was like all these different, and one
of them was one of the pieces of advice.
Never go back with an ex.
Well you anymore? Yeah.
It was a reason it didn't work out. She
didn't really want any more. I'm like,
that's so generalizing because how many
times have you gotten back with an ax
and have the best sex and the
history of the fucking universe?
We don't see each other for a long time.
People your heart.
We also send lots of
Christ.
What is this blue it miss you like
fucking clay face from that man.
You pretended to be Ra coast now with
his emotions. I'll get rained on you.
You Bitch and you'll turn back into
Clayface as all lower once in awhile.
Who the fuck are you done with?
Are you in love right now?
You tell me about your soul.
It's pretty right now
so rudely interrupted.
I don't even know something
about your feelings. Your
stupid. Oh, I was like, yeah,
be, if you get back with it,
I can't forget her heart.
They're going to hurt you again if that's
what he's that we just talked about
sex. Yeah, but it's a careful
your heart. Jesus Christ.
You should write songs that arrive.
Otherwise I would love to see
you like swaying back and forth.
Same cricket. It's like a real serious
stuff song. Hey there, Delilah,
you singing like a real serious song?
Like maybe like counting crow style.
Yeah.
Careful with your remote.
Really remote with it. No,
man, some of the best times ever in the
lyrics will be real quiet. He like, Eh,
no,
it's bad advice.
Right.
You know what it's like if it's
like saying there's no weirdness.
If you hang out with an extra
definitely fucker. Yeah.
And it's probably going to be
really fun. Oh yeah. Freeing.
Freeing because you'll know what it
is. Yeah. I mean, the idea that she's,
come on, man. Oh, I missed you
would like this for a while.
Sometimes it works sometimes. Sometimes
you apologize for how it went bad.
Yeah.
Sometimes you fucked like wild animals.
And then about five hours into it they
said something that reminds you how
fucking knowing they were and you're
like, oh my God, what am I doing, Jill?
Sobule he used to have a song
about, uh, about, um, uh,
prove my lack of heterosexuality lists.
Look, listen to Jill still believe,
but she's of a song about forgetting
guys like smile and then like, oh yeah,
it's such a great smile and forgetting
why she broke up with him. I was like,
Oh yeah, you tried to fuck all my friends.
That's right. I remember that part now.
But that smile when you over again.
It's very difficult.
If a girl has a nice ass to remember all
the mean girl has a great ass and she's
DTF. Yeah, you're hanging out.
You know you both single,
he got a couple of cocktails in you.
You just have it in me in that same town.
She just touches your
skin throughout here. Nah,
no little Kissy kissy kissing
your Dick is like a God damn crow.
Look who's back here.
Look who's back
ready to fuck.
Sometimes you get to talk,
she can just talk to you and
you're like up there it is. Yeah.
There's certain girls that are sex here.
Yeah,
and I'm sure there's certain guys that
are sexier too. I'm sure it's girls.
There's a lot of shit.
You and I both do that.
It's really fucking annoying
and it's a real vagina drier,
a real fucking close this show, right?
Every guy. I mean there's, yeah,
there's first for every girl. The
first time, first time I went through,
I saw a girl hot walking across
the whole like Faneuil hall.
I see her crossing the hallway.
The show's over and she was crossing from
the bathrooms back there all the way.
I'm looking at it the whole
way and then she gets up to me,
you are wicked funny how much?
Piss myself and I'm like,
there it goes.
That's designed that way to
keep them. Keep you. Yeah.
Nature designs it that way.
Keep them alone both to keep
you from wanting to do that.
Keep you from breathing. You've
been enlightened. You've escaped.
You escaped from that. That east
coast lightened shrimp fest this year,
August 9th 10th and 11th Oh shit.
Wants to participate.
Everybody who participates,
participates online simultaneously,
allegedly just do mushrooms.
August 9th 10th and 11th Yeah.
If you want to know how to find them.
I wrote a a or a what they're all about.
I wrote a primer online you can go to,
it's pretty much answers every question
you've ever had about mushrooms.
If you just Google Ari
Shaffir Shrimp Fest Primer,
are you worried about advertising shrimp
fest that you might be targeted by the
feds as what? As a shroom,
a supporter? Nah, man,
I live for, wow, you do live free.
Sometimes it's finding any reason
delivery at all. I'm like, Nah,
I don't think we're not coming.
We're not going to act on that.
It's the dumbest set of rules ever.
Yeah.
The fact that you go to cvs and buy a
gallon of whiskey and drink yourself to
death in the parking lot easily,
no one could stop you. Yeah.
The fact that that's possible.
I'm not facilitating any mushrooms.
I'm not pitching it for people. I'm
just fucking, yeah, you're right.
Everybody fucking, if you should
do it, we should all do it. Yeah.
That's how loss change anyway.
You know who shouldn't do it?
Who Does the training now?
He definitely showed he belonged
or 23 and even if they do it,
whatever, that seems old. I'd go,
you're arguing that that's fine. It
depends on their upbringing. Not Bad.
I don't know.
I had some cool friends in high school
with did it that I was always scared me,
but if we're going to allow people to
drink at 21 how can you not allow them to
take mushrooms too?
I say realistically 16 and a half.
That's not bad.
If you have community centers where you
could give these kids like a dose that
you know it's like super safe. Even
if they don't what is, he'll be fine.
What if the only way to get mushrooms,
like I'm not saying the kid should
do mushrooms, don't get me wrong,
let's go to your counselor or something.
Joe Rogan says kids should do mushrooms.
I'm not saying they should go do machines,
but if a 16 year old wanted
to do mushrooms and they
just got them on their own
and took them, absolutely, absolutely.
You don't know how strong it is.
You don't take,
don't get behind the wheel with this.
It's going to really fuck you
up and here's the reality.
How someone like you're actually to help
you with it. We'll do it. They did it.
When I was in high school,
there was always kids did mushrooms
and fucking listen to the wall.
You know what Vancouver's got in Hastings
in the fucking air, the heroin area.
They have safe shoot up places that smart.
We can go tell them what I'm taking.
So if you overdose,
they know they can like whatever help
you as best they can instead of like lips
hiding it. It's like they're going to
do it. Why are we not helping them?
So people are gonna do mushrooms.
Absolutely.
It's to talk to your guidance counselor
in high school about it. Yeah, it's smart.
Yeah. It's smart to do it
the right way. You take no,
you don't need an ounce absolute and you
have Jesus Christ and you're not taking
an ounce. You're going to
take us down. You're crazy.
If you freak out and then you're gonna
come back tomorrow when I talk to you
about how silicide infects the brain.
So I get a cab next time we'll take more.
Here's all the benefits of silicide.
Here's what they've shown.
John Hopkins University showed that.
Fascinating.
That's what if they had like certain
drugs that were not just legal but
respected,
like that's the real problem with things
like a psychedelic drug to research
them because, exactly. You can. We can
now. They can now more than ever before.
They can get the rights to and Strassman
did all those studies on DMT and then
new ones on DMT. They got new ones going
on right now. I you have to eventually.
Yeah. Shouldn't dd, but only if
it's legal under the God's law.
[inaudible] Winnipeg, but he
freaked me out. He was like,
he was like, Hey, here's,
it's just like, oh, really? Wow. It
was like, maybe if I get the right,
I think it goes, but if you don't
do it, don't give it to anyone.
Just throw it out.
Oh,
she's just crying like that. Don't
give it to anybody. What happened?
What's in this? Yeah. You
fucking crazy ass hole. No Way.
Mixing some he's fees.
He's got your phone and he knows
exactly where you are at all times.
You just got your phone's location
addresses hooked up to his laptop and he's
following you around in a
fucking bulletproof van.
Solid rubber tires like the punisher
throw you back there. You for a fuck ride.
Thinks you're funny. Huh? Amazing Racist.
My mother is half Mexican
flux your face while you're out cold.
Yeah. Not good dude. Don't do
it. You, you're very smart.
They told me they had mushrooms in,
in Hong Kong.
I found some people that were pacos lists
as these musicians are out there and
he sets up because I made a joke about
mushrooms and he goes uh, and he's like,
Oh yeah,
you know I get in my heart as I heard
it from the Joe Rogan experience podcast
and I was like, where did you get him out
of here? Cause they're in the woods, man.
Hong Kong has has woods
and it's humid is shit.
Like how do you know what to pick?
He goes,
I did a lot of research that you
cross reference it with pictures.
Mckenna talked about all the different
varieties that look like siliciden
mushrooms but it's super toxic poisons.
Yeah. Those are like the red ones.
I'm like,
I don't know man.
That seems like I would get out
warning for the summer plant. Yeah.
Like how many to miscarry?
I might take it into answers.
Drug dealer had nothing on that.
You know what the other problem with
that am Anita miscarry and one is never
talked to a single person who
had a real trip with them.
You take people had people taking them,
take them and they don't know.
Not really a mushroom. Right. You're
different than a regular mushroom. Well,
it's not silicide been right.
That's what else. That's what it is.
It's some other end
different psychoactive. Yeah,
and they think that the silicide that the
mushrooms are you getting now when you
get an Amanita miscarry for folks who
don't know what the fuck we're talking
about,
Google Ama,
Nida must scary a mushroom and religion.
Google religion,
because it's connected to a lot of
religions. It's connected to Santa Claus.
It's supposed to be the original Santa
Claus. Just Google it and figure it out.
Your honor.
It's fascinating,
but we've talked about it too
much on the podcast to go on,
but it's apparently different
than silicide, but it has another,
it's another different type of,
but I've never heard a single person
who's done it, who got off on it,
who had like a real psychedelic
experience. I did it with Doug, Doug,
and I did it on the day of the Iraq war.
Me and Doug and Yon Urban,
I remember. Yeah, yeah.
Yon Cooked it up and we drank this tea.
But Mckenna was saying that
those mushrooms may be,
they may be different genetically
and seasonally and yeah,
and also on there as well. If you've got
a cherries out of Susan, that was sweet.
Yeah, and apparently you, you got
to catch them in the right area.
You got to get them from the right,
like the right branch of this,
this mushroom tree that's grown or
whatever it is for calling New York.
Exactly.
Something along those lines.
But the ones that we're getting
today are just bullshit,
but apparently in some parts of the world,
some people know how to do it right.
The ones we'll cultivate them on purpose.
So letting them grow.
But it's not like silicide like psilocybin
mushrooms get you off no matter where
the fuck you are.
Every new owner who takes some
psilocybin mushrooms produce sales Simon,
that's what they are.
You know there's still a Feria cubensis.
There's a bunch of different
types of these similars,
but all of them that have silicide knock
you into fucking Jupiter that doesn't
work that way with the MNA to Mascara.
So a lot of people are confused about the
original use of the laminated miscarry
and his office.
Like there's like all this speculation
about it being attached to Christianity
and all these ancient religions and all
these people look at like all these old
cards and things from, from the 18
hundreds Santa Claus on Christmas card,
the all the Amnio miscarry attached to it.
That mushroom was like a big part of
Christian folk, Lord Carter Brothers too.
I don't know if that got them there.
They didn't know. No one knew.
So they just thought like, oh, I'll put
this. We're looking at mushroom man.
No one really. It was mainstream for
a small period of time in the 1970s,
but the Catholic Church bought off the
rights to the John Marco Allegro books.
Really? Yeah. Well one of them is
still available. The worst Catholics,
the new pope's. The good guy though,
seems like a nice guy. I guess
he, uh, this John Mako allegro guy wrote
a book called the sacred mushroom and the
cross.
And the reason why it was significant
is he was one of the scholars that was,
that's what helps start Christianity.
Oh no, that, yeah. They were like,
fuck this.
So they bought up the rights.
It connected the mushroom to
Jesus and a bunch of other shit.
They bought up the rights to it,
but they didn't buy up the
rights to the other one.
The Dead Sea Scrolls
in the Christian myth,
which is even more inflammatory in
its title. Sort of like to go, hey,
you can't silence silence me Dick Heads.
I'll just write another one and I'll
write it with another company. Right.
You can read that one.
You could still buy the sacred mushroom
and the cross you have to buy. Um,
you have to get it. Oh, actually,
young urbanites published
automatically illegally downloaded.
No Yon urban started
publishing them again. Yeah.
He started publishing it again two
years ago before that it was used.
I have a couple of copies of it,
but they're all really old.
I got him from a used bookstore.
That's Christianity and what doesn't
want people knowing that they didn't back
then,
that's for fuck short,
was that Simpsons where homer had a
crayon up his nose and it went through his
brain and made him super smart.
And he like came with a proof that
there's no such thing as God gave it to a
next door neighbor. So there's
no, there's no, no, no,
no. What Mr. Burns. Yeah. He goes, well,
I can't be true. And he's like,
oh, that. Yeah, that meant.
Oh Wow. And he goes, well,
we can't let this get out. He has a
burns it immediately. Wow. It's like, oh,
we can't let them be approved for no god.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fuck they would
do. Like what if they found today? Yeah.
Like what if they found in
controvertible evidence,
the Catholic Church found
in controvertible evidence
that Christianity was
designed by aliens to keep airline
until they, until they land to bury it.
I'll give you a, an analogy. You
wouldn't, they found like one of those,
let Colby want help me open one. You're
my only hope. They hit some thing again.
Shows up and explains how
humans are created. Oh, Ron
Hubbard. Alien. Hold close.
Banging a monkey. Yeah,
shooting the load into a monkey.
Shaking it up in a test tube point.
Human being pops out.
I think they keep going because the,
for the same reason Philip Morris kept
going, I found out. They're like, well,
we've got a good business going now.
Yeah,
well I'm not giving up my house
and based on nothing. Who Cares?
I have a castle in Tahiti,
so let people smoke cigarettes.
They're gonna smoke anyway.
Yeah, we tell them it's bad.
Will need to worship
the worship cigarettes
and the pig it even the silly bitch.
Jesus Christ.
How dare you.
I've got another story for you about what
you have such an interesting, go ahead.
Go ahead and pee red.
Uh,
for folks who don't know how such an
interesting take on religion and a
religious fundamentalist religion.
I write ideas cause he lived in a
crazy religious community in um,
not a kibbutz but one of those things in
Israel and studied the Talmud for like
12 hours a day every day and had all
these super specific rules and then went
from there to become within a couple
of years he was a dirty comedian,
which is amazing.
And like the exact opposite.
Like not only was he just a dirty
comic but he was doing like, you know,
like that those videos that he
was doing that was very, you know,
jokingly racist and he went from
like the opposite in immediately.
Well he went in very inflammatory shock
humor stuff that he thinks is funny.
Yeah, but we're talking about
you dude, how weird it is.
You're like one of the only dudes that
I know that went from being like a very,
in a very strict religious upbringing,
like about as strict as you can get to
becoming an open minded, dirty comedian.
He starts up mushroom festival.
Probably the only one who the
fuck else is there by herself.
There were a few others
that were religious. I got
out. Yeah, that's correct.
Pete Holmes. Yeah. There's
definitely a few that got out,
but not like as far out as you got kind
of linger around the edge. They dance.
It's pretty odd.
Mascara hates
religion. Kurt Mascara. Yeah,
we'll, we'll, we'll see.
He was a Jehovah's witness.
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
It was real deep in the a brother
so-and-so brother Joe Brother Brian.
That's unfortunate. Yeah, but
now he's fused at the same way.
These bring up these and he, he breaks
them down to, he says his thing.
It's like there's no justification in
the Bible for killing someone at war.
War has nothing to do.
There's no nations in the Bible.
You're not allowed to just cause Americans
attacking Iraq and not allowed to go
in and kill an Iraqi.
It's still do not kill.
It's a good point that there's no way
around it. There's no way around it. Yeah,
and he talks about stuff
like bacon up in kosher.
Then it always comes back to like
something. Why was that in the Bible?
I was like, oh cause it's made up.
Like why is it explanation of that?
Because it's clearly made up. Well it
has to be made up. Everything's made up.
Yeah. We know that.
Look, if it's not like,
could you imagine if you're dealing
with a religion that the people that all
practice that religion
are clearly elevated,
they're clearly in some incredible place
where they never lie and they're only
altruistic and their motives and their
super kind. They're super honest and they,
they,
they live universally.
There's no variation universally by
this intense moral code and this,
this, this projecting of love
and understanding everywhere.
So much so that like you felt it
when you were near them. Like wow,
that guy's clearly a Catholic priest.
You know what I mean?
Like if that was a thing, it was a thing
where these people would never lie.
They would never cover up.
Then what child rape they would know.
Then you might listen to that.
Then you might say, okay,
well maybe these guys really did find
the word of God and if the word of God
made a lot of sense, if it doesn't
make sense to people, well, you know,
God works in mysterious ways or retards
wrote a book and you're asking me to
follow up book that retards road they
used to sell it to, if you it enough,
they would sell you at these tickets.
I forgot what they're called,
but he's tickets into heaven.
Oh yeah.
And they started selling to rich people
and that, I mean the priests, the pope's,
they would do that in.
I could do it.
That's not even close to the worst thing
they've done. No, no, not even close.
Not even close. But how about the
last pope himself, the last pope,
the last guy is really,
he's guilty of crimes against humans,
crimes against nature. He was one of the
guys that diverted a priest, pedophiles.
He diverted them to new places, the
new market, and they did it again.
And it's like,
this is your head.
That means you're the head of your
organization is going to do that.
And you're still going to
be in that organization.
One of them raped a hundred deaf kids.
Oh,
wrap your head around that.
The priest was directly responsible for
moving a guy who raped like a hundred
delegates.
Okay.
The official numbers, like speculation
between 30 a hundred I mean,
this is going going on for 1500 years.
Oh yeah.
Probably since the beginning of the,
the,
the times where they made them sell a bit.
Probably when they started fucking kids,
probably when they started covering it up.
I mean,
it's amazing that you have one religion
and this is a religion that I come from,
by the way, one sec to the religion.
One Sec doesn't Christianity.
What specifically this I think of
Catholicism has his own religion.
I guess you're right.
It's just don't do this,
but the Christian Catholics don't
think of themselves as Christians.
You talked to a Catholic,
it's very rare that a Catholic considers
themselves a Christian and they
consider themselves Catholic.
Yeah. Egyptians don't
criticize ourselves as Arab,
but get over yourself there
in Africa though. Yeah.
There no one ever Arab shut up.
That's not a Rabia.
Who are you guys? An asshole.
But Catholics,
the one religion that's explicitly
connected to raping children.
Yeah. There's no other
than the newsletter. Look,
there's old people in all sex
of life that do terrible people.
It's systematic, systematic, systemic.
Over the years been covered up and
can and made to continue. Yeah.
Instead of going, Oh yeah, you, oh,
cares what you are. You've done this.
We're going to report you to the police
and try to get you to stop doing. It.
Used to be the responsibilities
of Catholic church. Now let it go.
Not Not even cover it up and
make sure it never happens again.
Discuss should go to jail as
a warning to other priests.
He was accused of crimes against
humanity by victims of sex abuse victims,
concrete to the international criminal
court accuses Pope Benedict and three
others of failing to prevent abusers
and hiding them and moving them.
Yeah, he's, he's a criminal.
He knew that this guy was fucking
kids and moved them to a place.
Just the idea that you are in charge of
administering the law in some way and
you're so ignorant,
you don't understand the recidivism
rates for child molesters.
Like that's criminally ignorant or
it's either that or you are complicit.
It's one of the two textures you're
trying to protect your business. Yeah.
Like this would be bad news for let's
cover it up. There's no other options,
right. Those are the only
two options. So why is he,
why is that guy wandering around?
Why isn't that guy locked in?
Kitchen one wasn't, remember those
people that in China that um, that the,
the baby powder formula,
the formula powder that I could be like
20 kids died from this baby powder. Yeah.
Um, and they found out what the CEOs of
that company were doing was putting this
enzyme in that would make a test
higher for purities. But this enzyme,
they just add it on their own, was also
had toxins in it and it killed 20 people.
They just murdered those people.
Chinese government said,
we're going to kill you all. Now. How
about what happened with d would GM what?
These fucking cars,
they cover it up.
I didn't believe Sam triple was on the
podcast and he was talking about it in
sort of vague terms. He didn't know
that though. Right? And I believe him.
I didn't believe Mike. You got it. You
had that wrong. They don't do that, dude.
I was convinced and then you
looked it up and I looked it up.
It was save them a dollar
a car. Oh, dollar car.
And they're willing to
risk someone else's life.
Dollar car would cost them a dollar car,
so it saved them a dollar
per car to let this happen.
I'm telling you, man, it's like
you think you're better than that.
But it's like organizations when
they go on check, floods become that.
Those become that horrible thing.
You need repercussions kind of car.
Do you drive? All right.
No, no. Tell people no, no.
And it was a Honda for a long
time. You're free now, right?
Three of them run around shit over at
some Bartman and CCS cards that a foreign
rent is easiest cry. That's a good
friend. What's he bar? It's fucking car.
He's got a second one here for
his wife and his wife's not here.
You've been lifting. Let
me see. Uber's Great Uber.
Uber's Great Uber. To me, it's a perfect
example of why the free market exists.
Where it's like cabs are assholes.
They don't pick up black people.
They fucking yell at you and may demand
that you pay fucking cash instead of
credit card, even though that's
not the rules. They just smell.
And then you're like, well guess what
a new organization pops up from that.
Shut it down time. Those guys,
you have downtime in between gigs.
Sometimes the limo drivers.
That's why Uber works so well.
And then there's Uber x which
uses like Prius's. Yeah,
and can you take people
around and presents the best?
Uber x is just comedians
have a job to do that.
How do you work for Uber x? Turn on the
APP and whenever you get you signed up,
whenever you're ready to go, ready
to work. And then here's what it is.
I asked them, what's do you have
to get checked out? They register.
They know who you are. I
don't know. I know they're
not paying people's insurance.
I know they're not playing
their drivers insurance.
So if a driver crashes on that driver,
so that's one of those special insurance
and I think they, they've gone,
they realized the checks, but I don't
think they're that crazy checks.
Like I had talked about how I got that
somebody was going to get murdered.
Here's the checked. Oh yeah, maybe
that, but here's the check is the,
is the rating system. Yeah.
Is A, if you get bad ratings,
if you're like drive all over, you don't
know. I think people won't take you. Yeah.
I got a guy in New York who
asked me to give him a rating.
You asked me to rate him on
a pig. It helped me. Yeah,
but if you like murder and kill somebody,
just take their phone and give
yourself five stars. That's great.
That's a great point.
Then just never does a rating.
So he's going to fight for the
life on a password protected phone.
That'll be your, your demise. We
though you wouldn't know who they are.
You would know who they are.
They come to pick you up?
Only if you have an iPhone
that's new. Yeah, but no,
they would know in the system
they came to pick you up.
You don't kill the other ones.
What about the android users?
They have the thumb prints. Now I'm
prince don't work on the android phones.
They don't, they don't want to start
a phone up that good one on the um,
the fucking big. That big
silver one. Cattle Moto X. No,
not the moto x was the other one.
HTC One mega or whatever it is.
They have fingerprints and in the back
getting off my data plan though. Ooh,
look at you. You're gangster. Just like
no data plan when I filed has five too.
Why would you do that?
Addiction. Oh, you're addicted.
So much time spent checking
social media and emails. I'm like,
I can get to that later. I'll tell you
what. I was on vacation for a few days.
Good. Right. You get off it occasionally.
I've got on Twitter to send out messages.
You know, like some
funny, I saw a picture,
I saw a funny saw deer walking around
and took a picture of this guy walking
around cause it gave zero
fucks just walking towards me.
And so I took a picture of him cause I
was just amazed at like there's d we're
so used to being around, people are just
walking around. Yeah. But other than that,
I didn't really go online, didn't
really read too much, just chilled,
relaxed feeling great. Shut your
phone off. Don't check my email
a little bit. Hang out with people I
see on elevators. As soon as the alert,
everyone takes it off and
it's like no one's even,
not that we need to make friends
all the time, but keep your eyes up.
Just like both are good.
It's good to have a phone cause it's good
to be able to get information quickly.
Go to a movies,
let's find out what's playing.
But you have to have discipline
with that. Yeah. And if I don't,
then it's like I don't, I don't know
if you know, I'll tell the people,
look it up on your phone or if we're
to why phonology in doing that,
like if you look at that trend,
that trend of being constantly
connected to your phone,
being afraid to leave your phone behind.
Do you think the technology,
if you sort of extrapolate like where's
that going that didn't exist before?
Like do you think that that's technologies
like drawing us in to like become
completely commodity
machines? Yeah. Borgess do.
Dunkin just got back from this virtual
reality conference and he fucking called
me up, tripping out, tried ripping out,
tripped me out on LSD. I Dunno.
He was completely just completely,
so I was in front of the Improv and we're,
we're talking on the phone. He goes,
dude, you're not going to fucking
believe this man. He goes,
this is bigger than the
invention of the camera.
This is bigger than the invention
of the Internet. He goes,
you go into a room and there's
a man in the room playing piano.
You have these virtual
reality reality goggles on.
You put them on and he goes and it's
almost indistinguishable. He goes,
you're watching a movie.
He goes,
it's age D and it's a film and it's
playing out in front of you in three
dimensions.
The way they make this film is they put
cameras all over a person's body and
then they, they film as this guy's
walking around, so as you move this,
this headset that you're wearing,
it picks up all the appropriate angles
from all the different cameras and it's
seamless. He said the first one, if you
got that oculus rift, the first one,
I played that at his place,
very pixelated, but it's
still fascinating, right?
Nauseous. That's gone. He
said, that's gone. He said,
I'll make sure you still
show that on a book,
but like a new prescription on my glasses
that you get nauseous for like half a
day. Those people are called
to fucking the changes here,
but Don Duncan was a freaking the fuck
out. It didn't give me nausea. It kind of,
I could see where it would happen.
Doug Benson, it made him sick, I think.
I don't know if you get
sick when you read in a car.
That's what I get really
sad when I read in a car,
I've gotten like where I've
rolled down the window, I'm like,
I'm not going to make it fresh air.
Well, I'm like, I am going to fucking,
I can't swallow quick enough.
Especially if it's a curvy road because
you don't know where the turns are
coming. So it's like it goes
against where, where you
know what? It's going to me,
it's just reading. It's just, it does
not even, they don't have to be curvy.
If I'm reading a car, if I try to read
a book or a newspaper and a car, I get,
I get sick,
but nothing.
That's the only time you get
on a bus or train easier.
I got sick flying in an FAA 18 flew with
the blue angels. I tried super hard,
but I got sick at the end. He barfed
we'll do a little puke and when did,
when did it, what's, what's the term? I
got sick to me. BARF. What did that, yeah,
I know, right? I didn't ever hear it
like that. And then I heard it and like,
and like books that way. How about
the term? I've got my eye on you.
I had my on her,
like she had her eye on you. Yeah.
She's got her eye on you. You know,
like if a girl's got the hots for you,
Hey Ari, she's got her eye on you.
She's looking at you. But it was that
fucking some ancient fucking evil shit.
Throw your honor. She
has her eye on, you know,
spell back when people talked
really weird, you know? Yeah.
I think that the only thing
that's lacking in, in,
in cell phones and stuff is the, it hasn't
gotten caught up by the etiquette yet.
You know, it's, people are now starting
to be like, hey, it's dinner. Put the,
put your phone away.
That is nice when people
do that and people are also
starting to really get into
retro shit.
Like think about that.
People are really into
like record players now.
And a lot of people were into old cars.
Three more minutes where I'm going to
turn into a pumpkin and realize, oh,
I got to tell you this thing. Oh
Shit. Tell a quick. So it's Shanghai.
They have these noodles and street
noodles. It was off the street meat,
which is delicious. There's expo say,
which I did not eat any street noodles.
This is the way they got their oil to
cook the noodles. They would. Brian,
I sent you a link. Do you think you
have another podcast in you right now?
Do you have another like hour and a half
or so hour? Maybe? Let's do another one.
I'll just end this pitch and we'll
do another one for an hour. Fuck it.
I've got nowhere to go.
Okay. My kids are asleep. Uh,
this episode of the podcast,
it was brought to you by Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com and use
the code word Joe is I it?
Did I say it right? Is
that it? I think so.
Yeah. They all have different ones.
Free trial and 10% off. Thanks.
Also to nature box.
Go to naturebox.com forward slash
Rogen and say 50% off your first box.
Awesome food too. I really love it a
lot. naturebox.com forward slash Rogen.
All right and uh,
go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t use
the Codeword Rogan save 10% off any and
all software minutes.
We'll be back tomorrow with um,
the guy from uh oh this is going to
be really interesting for you, Brian.
You're going to love this. The guy
from um, unbox therapy on bus got yeah,
he's got a great youtube channel and a,
it's all about technology.
It's all about new shit. So going in
line with what we're talking about,
we will find out about oculus
rifts and all kinds of shit.
And we have a show tomorrow night.
Oh Shit.
We got a show tomorrow
night at the Ice House. Dom,
I rera and Joey Diaz are in the big room.
And then there's another show that
we're doing in the little room and maybe
we'll get people back and forth from
over there too if they want to do extra
sets. Greg Fitzsimmons, Sarah, Tiana,
Tony Hinchcliffe. And myself in you.
And what about Christina p?
She had to jump out.
She's got some good Fitzsimmons Tony
Hinchcliffe, Sarah Tiana, you and May.
God dammit, son, fucking choke. All
right. Ari Shapiro on Twitter, a.
R. I. S. H. A. F. F. I. R.
If you're listening to only
this part of the podcast,
you're allowed to do that, but we're
going to continue in about two seconds.
It's good.